SUBCOMMITTEE FOR HEARING ON
STATE ADMINISTRATION TODAY WE
ARE IN ROOM TWENTY SEVEN THE
PANELISTS ON THE AGENDA ARE
APPEARING IN PERSON AND REMOTELY
USING. I SHALL BEGIN. GOOD
WELCOME BACK TO SUBCOMMITTEE FOR
HEARING ON STATE ADMINISTRATION
TODAY WE ARE IN ROOM ONE TWENTY
SEVEN THE PANELISTS ON THE
AGENDA ARE APPEARING IN PERSON
AND REMOTELY USING ONLINE
TECHNOLOGY WE ARE ACCEPTING
PUBLIC COMMENT AT THE END OF
THIS HEARING BOTH IN THE HEARING
ROOM AND ON THE PHONE THE PHONE
NUMBER TO CONNECT IS ON THE
COMMITTEE WEBSITE AND SHOULD
ALSO BE ON THE SCREEN IF YOU ARE
WATCHING OVER THE INTERNET. THE
NUMBER IS TOLL FREE 877-692-8957
THE PUBLIC ACCESS CODE IS ONE
THREE ONE FIVE ONE TWO SEVEN IF
YOU ENCOUNTER ANY PROBLEMS
PLEASE CONTACT THE ASSEMBLY
BUDGET COMMITTEE AT 916-319-2099
AND THE STAFF MEMBER WILL ASSIST
YOU WE ENCOURAGE THE PUBLIC TO
PROVIDE WRITTEN TESTIMONY BEFORE
THE HEARING. PLEASE SEND YOUR
WRITTEN TESTIMONY TO BUDGETS UP
FOR AT ASM DOT CA DOT GOP WITH
THAT LET'S TO ROLL CALL PLEASE.
YOU HEAR COOPER. LACKEY IS AREA
. WHAT THANK YOU I CAN I GET A
MOTION TO APPROVE THE VOTE ONLY
CALENDAR SOME OF THE OTHER OKAY
GREAT THANK YOU BROKE WITH
CAREER HI COOPER LACKEY I
MISSOURIAN WICKS. OKAY THAT
COUNT IS- THREE- THANK THE VOTE
ONLY COUNTS IS APPROVED THE
FIRST TIME THAT WE DO THIS AND
SO FAR IT'S SOMETHING FROM
EXCITED. WHAT THANK YOU MISTER
COOPER V. WE ARE GOING ACTUALLY
- WE'RE GONNA SKIP OVER ISSUE
ONE AS WE ARE WAITING FOR OUR
BUDGET CHAIR MR TANG TO- WANTED
TO BE PART OF THAT CONVERSATION
SO WE'RE GONNA START WITH ISSUE
NUMBER. ADDITIONAL STAFF
RESOURCE FOR THE OF TAX APPEALS
LET'S BEGIN. IN PERSON TESTIMONY
HOW AMAZING THANK YOU. YOUR
CAREER SHOULD I GO AHEAD. THANKS
AGAIN THANK YOU. HI MARK I HAVE
LINED THE DIRECTOR OF THE OFFICE
OF TAX APPEALS INSPIRED TO BE
WITH YOU AND THE MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE- DURING HER FOUR YEARS
WE'VE CONSISTENTLY STRIVE TO
ADHERE TO OUR CHARGE OF HAVING
FAIR VENUE FOR TAX APPEALS THAT
COME BEFORE US FROM TAXPAYERS
PAYING THROUGH THE AGENCIES OF
F. T. B. AND C. HFA. INDEPENDENT
ARE NOT CONNECTED WITH TAX
AGENCIES REPORTER TO THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE. IN OUR- AN
EXPERT TO SECURE THRUST MATTER
EXPERT ATTORNEYS REPLIED
INDEPENDENT LEGAL ANALYSIS. AS
WELL AS OUR TAX EXPERT ALJS MAKE
THE DECISION EACH APPEAL- ARE IN
PROCESS ARE TRANSIT TO TAXPAYERS
. AND TO U. S. POLICYMAKERS.
EACH TAXPAYER MAY REQUEST AND
RECEIVE AN ORAL HEARING ALL OUR
HEARINGS ARE ACCEPTABLE TO THE
PUBLIC EITHER IN PERSON. OR VIA
LIVE LIVE STREAMING ON. AND ONE
OF THE MOST IMPORTANT ASPECTS OF
THE OFFICE EACH APPEAL IT GOES
THROUGH THE PROCESS AND- WRIST A
WRITTEN OPINION THAT STATES THE
FACTS CITES THE APPLICABLE ON
PRIME DECISIONS AND EXPLAINS THE
RATIONALE. IN ADDITION NOW
EXPECT EXPERT COMMUNICATION CAN
OCCUR THAT IS ANY COMMUNICATION
WITH EIGHT AT PARTY TO A TAX
DISPUTE HAS TO BE- MUST OCCUR
WHEN BOTH PARTIES PRESENT. SO
SINCE WE STE. OUR FORTY AGO WE
POSE. ALMOST FOUR HUNDRED
DECISIONS ON OUR WEBSITE- AS
WELL AS PROVIDING THE TO
TAXPAYERS OF COURSE AND SOME OF
THESE HAVE BEEN MADE
PRESIDENTIAL LAND WE THOUGHT
THERE WAS ADDITIONAL GUIDANCE ON
NECESSARY FOR TAXPAYERS AND TAX
AGENCIES- IN TWO THOUSAND
NINETEEN TWENTY WE PUBLISH FOUR
HUNDRED THIRTY DECISIONS. IN
TWENTY TWENTY ONE LARGELY
BECAUSE OF COATED- WE PUBLISHED
ABOUT THREE HUNDRED FIFTY
DECISIONS. IN TERMS OF WORKLOAD
WHEN WE BEGAN IN JANUARY
FEBRUARY TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN
WE INHERITED ROUGHLY TWO
THOUSAND CASES. UPWARDS OF TWO
SEPARATE CASES ARE TRANSFERRED
FROM A CD TFA- IS PART OF THE AB
ONE OH TO PROCESS WHICH SET IN
PLACE- THE DIFFERENT TAX
AGENCIES- FOUR TWO THOUSAND
SEVENTEEN EIGHTEEN AND WHEN
COMBINED WITH OUR NEW APPEALS
ARE TOTAL APPEALS AND PAPERS
ABOUT TWENTY FOUR HUNDRED. CASES
THAT SO CALLED BACKLOG WAS
WORKED DOWN OVER THE NEXT A
COUPLE OF YEARS SO THAT WE HAD
SOMEWHERE IN THE RANGE OF
THIRTEEN HUNDRED FOURTEEN
HUNDRED CASES- BY BEING WORKED
ON AT ANY ONE TIME RIGHT NOW THE
ONLY BACKLOG THAT WE HAVE- IS
ABOUT A HUNDRED FIFTY HUNDRED
SIXTY CASES. THAT ARE FROM
TAXPAYERS WHO WOULD LIKE AN IN
PERSON HEARING AND AS AS ON. OUR
CHIEF DEPUTY WILL TALK ABOUT A
LITTLE BIT LATER- WE'VE BEEN IN
A VIRTUAL CONTEXT OF THE LAST
TWO YEARS SO THAT OUR AGAIN
WAITING FOR- IN PERSON HEARING
WHICH. WE EXPECT TO BEGIN NEXT
MONTH. ON IN JANUARY TWENTY ONE
WE BEGAN TO EXPERIENCE A SHARP
UPTICK UP. IN APPEALS AND A
CORRESPONDING INCREASE AND THE
CASE IS BEING WORKED. ARE SEVEN
TWENTY TWENTY ONE WE RECEIVED
ALMOST SEVENTEEN HUNDRED APPEALS
. AND IN TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO
ONE TRACK TO RECEIVE OVER TWO
THOUSAND PEELS- IN CONTRAST TO
NINETEEN TWENTY ONE WE RECEIVED
THIRTEEN HUNDRED. SO THIS IS
THAT IN. AS A THE WE'VE HAD IN
IN INVENTORY AND THAT BASICALLY
INTO THE ADDITIONAL STAFF.
REQUEST THAT WE HAD BEFORE- THE
ASSEMBLY TODAY. I DO WANT TO ASK
- YOUR EMBASSIES WHO IS OUR
CHIEF DEPUTY DIRECTOR TO JUST
HIGHLIGHT A COUPLE OF THINGS
THAT WE HAVE GOING ON IN TERMS
OF ADDITIONAL PROGRAMS. AND
TRYING TO GET A CHECK ADDITIONAL
EFFICIENCIES- GIVEN OUR EXISTING
RESOURCES SO. IF YOU'D LIKE TO
SPEAK TO SOME OF THOSE ISSUES.
YES I WOULD LOVE TO THIS IS
MERION BILL IS TO DEPUTY. WITH
THE OFFICE OF TAX APPEALS. AND I
WILL I WILL TO HIGHLIGHT SOME OF
THE PROGRAMS WE'VE BEEN PUSHING
FORWARD- TO CREATE GREATER
EFFICIENCIES ALSO- ENHANCE THE
EXPERIENCE THAT TAXPAYERS HAVE
AT THE OFFICE OF TAX BILL. THE
FIRST WOULD BE PASSAGE OF SB
NINETY TWO AND TWENTY NINETEEN
BUT AS OUR. SMALL CASE PROGRAM-
HE WAS CREATE AFTER THE TAX
PAYER. WILL KILL TO- OTA THEIR
K. HEARD BY A PANEL OF THREE J.
AND THEN TO NINETEEN S. B.
NINETY TWO AUTHORIZE. BALL TO BE
HEARD BY ONE JERRY- TO.
EFFICIENCY IN THE PROCESS AND
ALLOW. AN EXTRA PROCESS THAT
THEY WOULD BE ALLOW TO OPT INTO. YOU KNOW EMANATING FROM. THE
ATTY BEING- THERE ARE THOUSAND
DOLLARS LAST AND THOSE. STARTING
WITH SPEED FROM EACH OTHER.
THOSE APPEALS ARE HEARD HOW ARE
LAST AND FOR OF ALL BUSINESS
OWNERS WITH TWENTY MILLION. IN
RECEIPTS. FOR LAST THAN ANY
GIVEN YEAR- WE ESTAMOS THE
LEGISLATION WITH WORK ON RIGHT.
WE ADOPTED THOSE ARE. AND TWENTY
AND WE- PROGRAMS INTO TWENTY ONE
DOLLAR ONE OF TWENTY ONE. AND
TODAY WE HAVE OVER FOR TOP.
OFTEN THE PRO. AND WE'VE ALSO.
OUR FIRST ALL CASE- ARE ONE WE
YOU ARE WELCOME. TO READ. WE'VE
BEEN WORK ON IS- CREATING ALL MY
PORTAL. WE HAVE A LONG TIME
VERSION ONLINE. WHICH WE HAVE A
TEAM IF YOU THAT- TETON CA DOT
GOP. WHERE YOU CAN SUBMIT YOUR
APPEAL- ELECTRONICALLY TO US WE
HAVE BEEN CRACKED. OPAL PART
THAT WILL LAUNCH LIST. WHICH
WILL ALLOW TAX NOT ONLY. START
THEIR KILL. ON MY- BUT ALSO
ALLOW THEM TO MAKE REQUEST FOR
EXTENSION ONLINE THEY WILL ALSO
BE ABLE TO FEWER CASES IN OUR
PROCESS. AND HOPEFULLY TRACKWAY. THEIR CASES AND- BE ABLE TO
UTILIZE THOSE TOOLS AND HAVE TO
GO THROUGH OUR SYSTEM IN OUR
MAILING OR FAXING IT WILL CUT
OUT- A LOT OF THE TIME LAPSED
BETWEEN COMMUNICATIONS THAT
GENERALLY A CURRENT. ANOTHER
THING IS. TRANSITIONING BACK AND
MARK STATED- TO IN PERSON
APPEALS IN APRIL WE ARE ALLOWING
THE TAXPAYER TO CHOOSE WHETHER
OR NOT THEY WERE VIRTUAL OR IN
PERSON YEAH WE DON'T. TO DRIVE
THEIR APPEAL IT WOULD HEARING
AND IT'S SO AS WE MOVE BACK INTO
IN PERSON APPEALS WE HOPE TO DO
AND ADDRESS ANALYSIS- CURRENTLY
WE HAVE APPEALS ARE HEARD IN
SACRAMENTO FRESNO LOS ANGELES
COUNTIES AND WE WANT TO ENSURE
THAT WE ARE PROVIDING. A
CONVENIENT- CONVENIENT LOCATIONS
WE KNOW THE DRIVERS CAN BE A
LONG THOSE IN PERSON APPEALS FOR
THOSE TAXPAYERS THAT- OUGHT TO
HAVE AN IN PERSON APPEAL AND SO
WE WANT TO ENSURE THAT
INFORMATION DOWN ON A LARGE
GROUP OF TAXPAYERS WILL BE
CONFINED- A LOCATION THAT WOULD
WORK BETTER FOR THEM WE WOULD-
SEE IF WE CAN MAKE THAT HAPPEN
AND WORK WITH- STAKEHOLDERS THE
LEGISLATURE- TO MAKE THAT
AVAILABLE ATTACK. FUTURE AND
THOSE ARE BIG PART THAT WE BEEN
WORKING HERE- OKAY ARE COMING IN
KILL. THANK YOU MUCH APPRECIATED
DO WE HAVE ANY COMMON FROM THE
L. A. SEP KIRSTINE WITH THE L.
A- WE HAVE NO CONCERNS WITH THE-
PROPOSED AT BCP FOR OTA. THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. HI GOOD
AFTERNOON CRYSTAL THE DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE WE SUPPORT THIS
PROPOSAL- AVAILABLE TO ANSWER
ANY QUESTIONS AND MEMBERS NOW.
THANK YOU ARE THERE ANY COMMENTS
OR QUESTIONS FROM THE COMMITTEE
SEEING NONE CAN I GET A MOTION
TO APPROVE THE STUFF. GREAT TECH
AND I WILL SECOND THAT WE WILL
WAIT FOR THE ROLE CALL ON THAT
IN THE THAT OPEN FOR THE MOMENT
LET'S GO BACK TO THANK YOU TO
THE PANELISTS STUFF FOR ISSUE
TWO WE'RE GONNA GO BACK TO ISSUE
NUMBER ONE. THE OVERSIGHT OF
CALIFORNIA'S TAX- DEPARTMENTS IN
A TWENTY THE LEGISLATURE TWO
BILLS AB ONE OH TWO AND AB ONE
THIRTY ONE THAT CREATED TWO NEW
DEPARTMENTS. AND TRANSFERRED ALL
OF THE BOARD OF EQUALIZATION
STATUTORY DUTIES FOR THE TO
THESE DEPARTMENTS THE B.
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF TAX AND
FEE ADMINISTRATION IN THE OFFICE
OF TAX APPEALS THE BE- WE
MAINTAINED. ITS CONSTITUTIONAL
OVER TAXES AND I'LL CALL THE
BEVERAGE INSURANCE AND PROPERTY
THIS ISSUE IS DESIGNED TO
PROVIDE OVERSIGHT OVER THE TWO
NEW DEPARTMENTS AS WELL AS THE
B. O. E. FOR YEARS AND TO THIS
TRANSITION. LET'S BEGIN. MISTER
ASSET KIRSTEIN ARE YOU ON THE
LINE IF SO PLEASE YES. SO SORRY
YEAR NO THAT'S FINE THANK AYE
AYE FORGET THAT WERE IN PERSON
NOW APOLOGIES NO NO PROBLEM
MADAM CHAIR US YOU I'M CHRISTINE
WITH THE L. A. L. AND I'LL BE
PROVIDING A BRIEF OVERVIEW. OF
THE MAJOR CHANGES THAT THE STATE
MADE TO ITS TAX AGENCIES IN
TWENTY SEVENTEEN AND OF SOME OF
THEIR SUBSEQUENT ACTIVITIES AND
WE'VE DISTRIBUTED A HANDOUT TO
ACCOMPANY MY TESTIMONY SOME
VERSIONS WHICH ARE AVAILABLE IN
PAPER NOW- I'LL START ON THE
FIRST PAGE OF THE HANDOUT- WHICH
HAS A LITTLE FLOW CHART. IT WAS
. THE ILLUSTRATING THE LANDSCAPE
BEFORE THE TWENTY SEVENTEEN LAWS
SO AT THAT TIME- THE- TWO MAIN
TERA AGENCIES WORD THE FRANCHISE
TAX BOARD KNOWN AS F. T. B. AND
THE- STATE BOARD OF EQUALIZATION
KNOWN AS B. O. E. SO I HAVE TO
BE ADMINISTERED AND CONTINUES TO
ADMINISTER- PERSONAL AND
CORPORATE INCOME TAXES. AND AT
THAT TIME B. O. E. ADMINISTERED
THE SALES AND USE TAX AS WELL AS
DOZENS OF SMALLER TAX AND FEE
PROGRAMS. I AND AT THAT TIME B.
O. WE ALSO HEARD APPEALS FOR ALL
STATE TAXES- ALTHOUGH DOE WAS
ESTABLISHED UNDER THE STATE
CONSTITUTION MOST OF ITS DUTIES
WERE ASSIGNED BY STATUTE. I AM
JUST A NOTE FOR SIMPLICITY THIS
FIGURE AND A SIMILAR ONE LATER
AND HANDED DO NOT DEPICT VARIOUS
OTHER STATE AND LOCAL ENTITIES
THAT ARE THAT ARE INVOLVED IN
THESE. TAX PROGRAMS. SO TURNING
TO THE NEXT PAGE OF THE HANDOUT
I WILL DESCRIBE THE TWENTY
SEVENTEEN LAWS THAT CHANGED THIS
LANDSCAPE. BOE'S STRUCTURE
COMBINES. ASPECT AND FEATURES OF
THE LEGISLATIVE EXECUTIVE AND
JUDICIAL BRANCHES OF GOVERNMENT
AND DUE TO THE CONFLICT INHERENT
IN THIS STRUCTURE OUR OFFICE AND
OTHERS. ALL LONG EXPRESSED
CONCERNS ABOUT BOE'S ABILITY TO
OPERATE EFFECTIVELY.
ADDITIONALLY IN MANY YEARS AND
MONTHS LEADING UP TO THE TWENTY
NINETEEN LAWS. ALL RIGHT AND
OTHER ENQUIRIES- INDICATED A
VARIETY OF PROBLEMS WITH BOE'S
OPERATIONS INCLUDING SOME
ACTIONS THAT WERE NOT CONSISTENT
WITH LEGISLATIVE DIRECTIVES AND
SO IN TWENTY SEVENTEEN THE
LEGISLATURE AND THE GOVERNOR
RESPONDED TO THESE CONCERNS BY
PASSING AND SIGNING AB ONE OH
TWO AND AB ONE THIRTY ONE. SO
THESE LAWS TRANSFERRED BOE'S
STATUTORY RESPONSIBILITIES TO
TWO NEW ENTITIES THE DEPARTMENT
OF TAX AND FEE ADMINISTRATION
KNOWN AS CD TFA AND THE OFFICE
OF TAX APPEALS WHICH YOU JUST
HEARD FROM KNOWN AS AU TA- AND
BE- WE RETAINED ITS
CONSTITUTIONAL AUTHORITY OVER
TAXES ON PROPERTY INSURANCE AN
ALCOHOLIC BEVERAGES. TURNING TO
THE NEXT PAGE OF THE HANDOUT.
WE'VE GOT ANOTHER FLOW CHART
HERE IN THIS ONE DEPICTS THE
CURRENT STRUCTURE OF STATE TAX
ADMINISTRATION AND APPEALS- SO
THROUGH INTERAGENCY AGREEMENTS
CD TFA CARRIES OUT MANY
ADMINISTRATIVE TASKS RELATED TO
TAXES ON INSURANCE AN ALCOHOLIC
BEVERAGES ON BEHALF OF B. O. E.
AND SO BE ALWAYS TAX
ADMINISTRATION EFFORTS ARE
LARGELY FOCUSED ON. PROPERTY
TAXES. R. O. T. A. THE OFFICE OF
TAX APPEALS IS RESPONSIBLE FOR
HEARING MOST TAX APPEAL CASES
INCLUDING INCOME TAXES AND SALES
TAXES. ARE THESE CASES ARE HEARD
AS AS YOU HEARD BY PANELS OF
THREE ADMINISTRATIVE LAW JUDGES
IN ONE OF THREE LOCATIONS
SACRAMENTO FRESNO LOS ANGELES.
SO TURNING TO THE NEXT PAGE OF
THE HANDOUT HERE I'M JUST GOING
TO COVER SOME BRIEF HIGHLIGHTS-
FOR THESE THREE AND CITIES OVER
THE LAST HALF DECADE. SO CD TFA
. I HAS IT. NEW CANNABIS TAXES-
THAT WERE PASSED BY THE VOTERS
IN PROP SIXTY FOUR TWENTY
SIXTEEN. DAVE I IMPLEMENTED THE
EXPANDED USE TAX NEXUS
ESTABLISHED BY THE TWENTY
EIGHTEEN- SO U. S. SUPREME COURT
WAYFAIR RULING AND THEY HAVE
COMPLETED. A MAJOR I. T. PROJECT
. RBOT PROPOSITION NINETEEN THIS
NEW PROPERTY TAX RULES AND THEY
ALSO OVER THE COURSE OF SEVERAL
YEARS AND EXPERIENCE A VERY
SUBSTANTIAL FLUCTUATIONS- THE
SHARE OF A STAFF POSITIONS THAT
HAVE BEEN FILLED- THE OFFICE OF
TAX APPEALS IS HEARD TAX APPEALS
AND- ISSUE WRITTEN OPINIONS
WITHIN A HUNDRED DAYS. OF EACH
HEARING US SINCE THE BEGINNING
OF THE PANDEMIC THEY'VE BEEN
HEARING CASES REMOTELY AS YOU
HEARD FROM FROM THERE- STAFF-
ALTHOUGH THE OFFICE PLANS TO RE
COMMENCE IN PERSON ORAL
HEARINGS. IN SACRAMENTO AND LOS
ANGELES IN APRIL AND JUST FOR
YOUR REFERENCE- THE LAST PAGE OF
THE HANDOUT LISTS EXPENDITURES
FOR THESE THREE ENTITIES FOR CD
TFA B. O. E. N. O. T. A. FROM
JUST BEFORE THE MAJOR CHANGES
AND- THE CURRENT FISCAL YEAR
TWENTY ONE TENTY TWO. AND SO
THAT CONCLUDES MY PREPARED
REMARKS AND- WE'D BE HAPPY TO
TAKE QUESTIONS IF YOU HAVE.
HELLO THIS IS NICK MADURO'S
DIRECTOR OF C. T. F. A. OKAY SO
MUCH. I'M I'VE HAS. CHAIR AND
MEMBERS THE COMMITTEE MY NAME IS
NICK WITH AND I'M THE DIRECTOR
OF THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
TAX AND FEE ADMINISTRATION THANK
YOU FOR INVITING ME TO JOIN YOU
TODAY WITH AN UPDATE ON THE
STATE OF THE DEPARTMENT SINCE
ITS CREATION UNDER AB ONE OH
TWO. FOR ALMOST FIVE YEARS I'VE
HAD THE PRIVILEGE TO WORK
ALONGSIDE THE AMAZING TEAM AT CD
TFA. PARTICULARLY GIVEN THE MANY
ISSUES THAT EXISTED UPON THE
DEPARTMENT'S CREATION. WE'VE
BEEN FOCUSED ON FAIRLY AND
EFFICIENTLY ADMINISTERING THE
THIRTY SEVEN SOON TO BE THIRTY
EIGHT. TAX AND FEE PROGRAMS IN
OUR PURVIEW. WELL WE'RE ALWAYS
STRIVING TO IMPROVE I AM PLEASED
TO REPORT WE'VE MADE SUBSTANTIAL
PROGRESS. CLOSE LONGSTANDING
AUDIT FINDINGS ENHANCE INTERNAL
CONTROLS WOULD BE LAW MORE
TRANSPARENT. INCLUDING BY
PROVIDING THE PUBLIC ACCESS TO
AN OPEN DATA PORTAL IT'S A GREAT
RESOURCE FOR ANYONE INTERESTED
IN CALIFORNIA'S. OR ECONOMIC
CONDITIONS. WE'VE UNIFIED THE
DEPARTMENT'S POLICIES AND
PROCEDURES WHERE PREVIOUSLY
TAXPAYERS COULD GET DIFFERENT
TREATMENT DEPENDING UPON WHICH
REGION OF THE STATE THEY- AS THE
COMMITTEE KNOWS. WE'VE WE'VE
MOVED ALL OF OUR TAX PROGRAMS
OFF OF THE OLD MAINFRAME AND
ONTO OUR NEW CENTRALIZED REVENUE
OPPORTUNITY SYSTEM ACROSS. THE
PROJECT CAME IN ON TIME AND
UNDER BUDGET AND I'D LIKE TO
THANK YOU ALL FOR YOUR STRONG
SUPPORT OF THAT VITAL EFFORT.
LET ME TAKE JUST A MINUTE TO
TALK ABOUT THE IMPROVED
EFFICIENCY GAINS OVER THE PAST
FIVE YEARS. ALMOST ACROSS THE
BOARD PROCESSING TIMES HAVE BEEN
CUT DRAMATICALLY. LOOKING AT OUR
REFUNDS FOR EXAMPLE. WHEN I
FIRST STARTED I GET CALLS FROM
TAXPAYERS DESPERATE FOR REFUND
CHECKS. ONE HOLIDAY SEASON THAT
FIRST CHRISTMAS I WAS IN THE JOB
I GOT A CALL FROM A SMALL
BUSINESS OWNER WHO WAS DESPERATE
HIS REFUND BECAUSE HE NEEDED IT
TO AFFORD. CHRISTMAS PRESENTS
FOR HIS KIDS. IN FISCAL YEAR.
TWENTY SEVENTEEN TWENTY EIGHTEEN
JUST ELEVEN POINT 8% OF REFUND
CLAIM WERE PER. WITH THIRTY
DAYS. THIS YEAR WE'RE- 80% OF
OUR REFUND CLAIMS WITHIN THIRTY
DAYS THE MAJORITY OF THOSE.
WITHIN TEN DAYS. OUR PETITIONS.
ALSO SEEM HUGE IMPROVEMENTS
CITIES AND COUNTIES SUBMIT
PETITIONS FOR REDISTRIBUTION
WHEN THEY THINK A TAXPAYER HAS
MISSED ALLOCATED LOCAL TAX ON
THEIR RETURN. WE LITERALLY HAD
CASES IN THE BACKLOG OVER ALMOST
TWO DECADES OLD. THE TEAM HAS
WORKED HARD AND SMART- TO REDUCE
THAT INVENTORY BY NEARLY 75%
WE'RE GETTING MORE DONE FASTER
THAN EVER BEFORE. SIMILARLY IN
ARE TRYING TO PROCESS OFFERS IN
COMPROMISE WHICH ALLOW TAXPAYERS
WITH LIMITED MEANS TO SATISFY
OUTSTANDING LIABILITIES. THE
PROCESSING TIME IS DROPPED FROM
SIX TO TEN MONTHS TO UNDER
THIRTY DAYS. THESE ARE JUST A
FEW EXAMPLES OF THE GREAT WORK
THE TEAM IS DOING AND ALL OF
THESE IMPROVEMENTS CONTINUE TO
FEED ON ONE ANOTHER DRIVING
FURTHER PRODUCTIVITY GAINS.
THROUGH A RELENTLESS FOCUS ON
IMPROVING OUR OPERATIONS WE'VE
MANAGED TO DO MORE WITH LESS.
REVENUE IN THE PROGRAMS WE
ADMINISTER HAS GROWN FROM
SEVENTY POINT FOUR BILLION IN
FISCAL YEAR SEVENTEEN EIGHTEEN
OUR FIRST YEAR OF OPERATION. TWO
EIGHTY ONE POINT FIVE BILLION
LAST FISCAL YEAR AND WE
ANTICIPATE THIS YEAR WILL BE UP
CLOSE TO NINETY BILLION. OVER
THAT TIME THE COST ADMINISTER
HAS DROPPED FROM EIGHTY FOUR
CENTS PER HUNDRED DOLLARS IN
REVENUE. IN SEVENTEEN EIGHTEEN
TO THIS YEAR WHEN WE THINK THAT
NUMBER WILL BE BELOW SEVENTY
CENTS PER HUNDRED DOLLARS IN
REVENUE. AT ONE SOURCE OF THE
SAVINGS HAS BEEN OUR PERSONNEL
COSTS AND I UNDERSTAND THAT THE
COMMITTEES HAD CONCERNS. IN THE
PAST REGARDING VACANCIES OF
COURSE WE'RE ALWAYS HIRING BUT
WE ARE NOW FOCUSED ON HIRING
ONLY WHERE THE POSITION IS
ABSOLUTELY NEEDED. AND WE'RE
FOCUSED ON STREAMLINING OUR
PROCESSES FIRST SO WE ARE JUST
HIRING PEOPLE INTO AND IF
INEFFICIENT SYSTEM. OUR NATURAL
VACANCY RATE IS RUNNING A BIT
HIGHER THAN USUAL AT THE MOMENT
WE'RE SEEING A LOT OF
RETIREMENTS IT SEEMS PEOPLE
POSTPONED RETIREMENTS DURING
COVERT WHEN THEY- AT. COULDN'T
GO ON TRIPS AFTER THEY- RETIRED
. AND FURTHERMORE AS SOME OF OUR
TREATMENTS ARE PROVING MORE
DIFFICULT THAN IN THE PAST I'M
SURE YOU'VE ALL SEEN THE NOW
HIRING SIGNS ALL OVER THE PLACE
AND IN FACT THEIR FAST FOOD JOBS
THEY'RE NOW. PAYING MORE THAN
MANY OF OUR ENTRY LEVEL TAX JOBS
AND THOSE ARE LEADING TO SOME
INCREASED VACANCIES. WE ARE
THOUGH COMMITTED TO WORKING TO
RIGHT SIZE OUR TEAM AND MAKE
SURE WE HAVE THE RIGHT PEOPLE IN
THE RIGHT POSITIONS TO GET THE
WORK DONE AND- YOU'RE WORKING
WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
TO FIGURE OUT BUT THAT RIGHT
NUMBER SHOULD BE. AND WE'RE
COMMITTED TO WORKING WITH ME
STAFF IS NOT EFFORT PROGRESSES
AS WELL. THAT'S A DIFFICULT LONG
TERM PROJECT THOUGH AND IT'S
EVEN MORE COMPLICATED GIVEN THAT
OUR GENERAL FUND ALLOCATION
IMPACTS FUNDS AVAILABLE FROM
SPECIAL TAX FUNDS. AND FROM
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS ON WHOSE
BEHALF WITH MINISTER THE BRADLEY
BURNS AND DISTRICT TAXES. IN
CONCLUSION. THE TEAM AT CTF. HAS
DONE A GREAT JOB IN THE FACE OF
REAL HEADWINDS INCLUDING THE
PANDEMIC OVER THE PAST TWO
YEARS. I'D LIKE TO THANK THE
WHOLE TEAM FOR THEIR INCREDIBLE
WORK. AND LIKE TO THANK THE
COMMITTEE FOR YOUR STRONG
SUPPORT OVER THE PAST FIVE
YEARS. I'D BE HAPPY ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS THAT. ANY MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE MAY HAVE. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU OUR NEXT
PENALISES MARC I BILL DIRECTOR
OF OTA. YEAH. WE GO AHEAD AND
SHARE. IT MARKER MERRIAM- E. R.
IF YOU'D LIKE US TO. RESENT THE-
MATERIAL WE WENT THROUGH- SORT
OF A HIGH LEVEL VIEW OF. THE
OFFICE OF TAX APPEALS AND IT'S
ITS WORKLOAD. AND IT'S A BUDGET
REQUEST- WE CAN WE CAN I'M HAPPY
TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS WERE
HAPPEN ANY ANSWER ANY ADDITIONAL
QUESTIONS YOU MAY HAVE ON. THE
GOINGS ON AT OTA WE ARE GOING TO
REVERT TO IN PERSON HEARINGS IN
THE NEXT MONTH AND- WE'RE GOING
TO CONTINUE OUR REMOTE HEARINGS
AS WELL. I'M NOT SURE IF THERE
ARE ANY INTENTIONAL. THAT- THE
COMMITTEE HAD AT THIS POINT.
THANK YOU WE WANT TO BRING THE
FLEMING EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF
THE WEEK. GOOD AFTERNOON I'D
SHARE CARILLO AND OPERABLE
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE I AM
AND THE FLEMING THE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF THE STATE BOARD OF
EQUALIZATION I THANK YOU FOR
THIS OPPORTUNITY TO PARTICIPATE
IN TODAY'S. DISCUSSIONS HAVING
BEEN WITH THE B. O. B. SINCE
TWENTY ELEVEN I BELIEVE THAT I
DO HAVE A UNIQUE PERSPECTIVE TO
OFFER TO TODAY'S DISCUSSION.
HAVING EXPERIENCED THE BEFORE
DURING AND AFTER OF THE
ENACTMENT OF AB ONE OH TWO AND
TWENTY SEVENTEEN. PLEASE ALLOW
ME MEMBERS TO PROVIDE A VERY
BRIEF HISTORY AND ALL STAFF IS
GONE THROUGH ALREADY A BRIEF
HISTORY OF THE BEER WE AS YOU
KNOW AND AS WAS STATED. IN
EIGHTEEN SEVENTY NINE THE BILL
WE WAS A STAFFERS UNDER THE
CALIFORNIA CONSTITUTION TO
OVERSEE CALIFORNIA'S PROPERTY
TAX SYSTEM. IN ESSENCE MEMBERS
WE ARE CHARGED TO ENSURE EQUAL
AND FAIR ASSESSMENT AND
VALUATION OF PROPERTY. W. E. IS
THE ONLY ELECTED TAX FOR IN THE
COUNTRY AND IS COMPRISED OF FOUR
EQUALIZATION DISTRICT MEMBERS
AND THE STATE COMPTROLLER. OVER
THE PAST CENTURY WE ALWAYS
RESPONSIBILITIES WERE EXPANDED
TO INCLUDE TWO ADDITIONAL
CONSTITUTIONAL PROGRAMS AND OVER
THIRTY STATUTORY AND FREE
PROGRAMS INCLUDING THE SALES AND
USE TAX PROGRAM. THE TWENTY
SEVENTEEN LEGISLATION REFER ARTS
. THROUGH THE EIGHT MINUTES. OF
THE CONSTITUTION PROGRAMS AND AS
WE STATED BEFORE THAT'S PROPERTY
TAX THE ALCOHOLIC BEVERAGE TAX.
AND THE TAX ON INSURERS. THE
RESPONSES. ARE CURRENT SUPPORT
BY A- TWO. EMPLOYEES WHO PERFORM
A RANGE ROLES. INCLUDING TAX
ADMINISTRATION FUNCTIONS LEGAL
STATE ADMINISTRATION TAXPAYER
RIGHTS ADVOCACY COMMUNICATIONS
E. AND A FEW MORE. OUR CURRENT
VACANCY RATE IS APPROXIMATELY
17% WITH ABOUT THIRTY
RECRUITMENTS AND ACTIVE OUR
PROGRESS. WITH A REFINED SCOPE
OF TAX PROGRAMS THE VIEW WE
CONTINUES TO AFFECTED RIGHT
MINISTER ARE TAX PROGRAMS WHAT
GREATER EFFICIENCIES AND QUOTING
STRENGTHENING OUR WORKFORCE
INVESTING IN OUR SUBJECT ATTER
EXPERTISE AND PROVING AND
REFINING OUR PROCESS THESE
MODERNIZING OUR TECHNOLOGY
SYSTEMS AND ENRICHING OUR
TAXPAYER EDUCATION AND OUTREACH
DUTIES. THIS IS ALL TO ENSURE
THAT OUR TAXPAYERS AND
CALIFORNIA'S AT LARGE CONTINUE
TO RECEIVE THE PROPERTY TAX
REVENUES WHICH SUPPORT OUR LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS AND OUT WITH THIRTY
SIX POINT NINE BILLION DOLLARS
AND LOCAL PROPERTY TAX REVENUE
AN ADDITIONAL FORTY THREE
BILLION DOLLARS AND FUNDING FOR
OUR SCHOOLS. THIS BY THE WAY IS
A SIX INCREASE OVER FISCAL YEAR
TWENTY NINETEEN TWENTY TWENTY.
TO CONTINUE MEMBERS AND TERMS OF
EFFICIENCIES GAINED CENTS TO
RESTRUCTURE YES THERE ARE SOME.
MOST NOTABLY AS OUR OPERATIONAL
AGILITY. A SMALLER
INCLUDES A REDUCED HIERARCHICAL
STRUCTURE. THAT FLATTER
ORGANIZATION MAKES DECISION
MAKING. POLICY DEVELOPMENT
SUCCESSION PLANNING MANAGEMENT
AND GENERAL COMMUNICATIONS AND
OUR PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT FOR
STAFF SIGNIFICANTLY MORE AGILE
AND MUCH MORE HANDS ON. THIS
BENEFIT IS PROVING TO BE A
SPECIALLY HELPFUL MEMBERS FROM
WHEN THE INITIAL STAY AT HOME
ORDER WORK PHASE BEGAN TO DOUBT
DURING THIS EMERGING TELEWORK
HYBRID WORK MODEL. THESE OPERATE
EFFICIENCY HAPPEN THE- WITH ITS
BECAUSE- PRO. MORE AND OF.
BRIEFLY IF I MAY OUR
CONSTITUTIONAL ROLE FOR THE
ADMINISTRATION OF THE ALCOHOLIC
BEVERAGE TAX AND TAX ON INSURERS
PROGRAMS CONTINUES FOLLOWING THE
TWENTY SEVENTEEN LEGISLATION.
THE DIFFERENCE NOW MEMBERS IS
THAT SOME SPECIFIC FUNCTIONS FOR
EXAMPLE THE TAX COLLECTION
PROCEDURES FOR THE ALCOHOLIC
BEVERAGE TAX PROGRAM ARE
OUTSOURCED VIA AN INTER AGENCY
AGREEMENTS TO CD TFA. THAT'S
LINE WITH THE PROVISIONS OF
GOVERNMENT CODE FIFTEEN FIVE
SEVENTY DOT THIRTY ONE. THERE
ARE EFFICIENCIES GAINED WITH
THIS APPROACH RESULTING FROM
CITY TO HAVE BASED TECHNOLOGY
SYSTEM AND THEIR TAX BILL HAND
COLLECTION EXPERTISE. AND IT'S
BEEN A PLEASURE WORKING WITH
NICK. IN FACT OTHER STATE
AGENCIES HAVE SIMILAR
INTERAGENCY AGREEMENTS FOR CITY
CHAIRED A SERVICES AS WELL. IT
IS IMPORTANT TO NOTE THAT THE B.
ONLY REMAINS CONSTITUTIONALLY
AND JURISDICTION WAY RESPONSIBLE
FOR THESE FUNCTIONS IN ADDITION
TO BE A WEEK DIRECTLY PERFORMS.%
ALL LEGAL AND JUDICIARY
FUNCTIONS THE APPEALS FOR
COUNTRY FANS REDETERMINATION
DIALS EXCEPT FOR THE ALCOHOLIC
BEVERAGE TAX AND TAX AND
INSURANCE PROGRAMS. WE ALSO
PERFORMED THE TAXPAYER RIGHTS
ADVOCATES SERVICES FOR THE
ALCOHOLIC BEVERAGE TAX. AND
TRUMP'S MEMBERS OF OUR
RELATIONSHIP WITH SEATS IF I AS
YOU KNOW AS OF THE TWENTY
SEVENTEEN STATUTE GOVERNMENT
CODE SECTION FIFTEEN FIVE
SEVENTY DOT TWENTY EIGHT WORDS
GOODNIGHT CD TFA SUPERVISED BE A
WEEK WITH ADMINISTRATIVE AND
PERSONNEL SERVICES WHICH
INCLUDE. BUDGETING AND
ACCOUNTING IN GENERAL FINANCE
FUNCTIONS CONTRACTS AND
ACQUISITIONS FACILITIES
TECHNOLOGY SERVICES JUST TO NAME
A FOR YOU. WE APPRECIATE THE
SERVICES PROVIDED BY OUR
PARTNERS AND WHILE THE PERSONAL
RELATIONSHIPS ARE HEALTHY AND
FINE THE CHALLENGES ARE SIMPLY
RELATED TO WORK WHAT. COMPETE
PRIORITIES WORKFORCE CITY
INCLUDING THE ADMINISTRATIVE
OVERHEAD AS YOU CAN IMAGINE-
PROCESSING WORK ACROSS. TWO
DISTINCT AGENCIES. BLACK MEMBERS
I MANY OTHERS AGENTS. HIS FACE
IS A CHALLENGE. TO LIVE A SENSE
SUBJECT MATTER EXPERTISE
SPECIFICALLY IN OUR PROPERTY TAX
AREA. DUE TO RETIREMENTS CAREER
CHANGES BOTH PRE AND POST
PANDEMIC AND OTHER WORKFORCE
ATTRITION FACTORS. THIS FACTORS
COUPLED WITH AN AGE AND OUTDATED
JOB CLASSIFICATION AND
COMPENSATION MODEL THIS TOPIC IS
OUTSIDE OF THE SCOPE OF TODAY'S
HEARING I DO UNDERSTAND THAT BUT
IT'S WORTHY TO NOTE AS WELL AS
WELL AS WE ALL WORK TO ENSURE
THAT CALIFORNIA'S PROPERTY TAX
SYSTEM CONTINUES TO THRIVE BY
DEVELOPING A TRACKING THE NEXT
GENERATION OF EXPERTS TO THIS
INDUSTRY. TO CONCLUDE MEMBERS.
LOOKING BACK TO TWENTY SEVENTEEN
TO NOW MANY OF OUR GOALS AND
OBJECTIVES HAVE BEEN ACHIEVED.
ALL THE ISSUES THAT TRIGGER THE
TWENTY SEVENTEEN RESTRUCTURE
HAVE BEEN REMEDY I COOPER
LEGISLATION AFFECTED POLICIES
AND CONTROLS STRONG LEADERSHIP
AND A PROFESSIONAL WORKFORCE
WILL PERFORM THEIR DUTIES WITH
GREAT INTEGRITY. DO WE HAS
CONTINUED TO DELIVER ITS
ESSENTIAL SERVICES FOR THE
BENEFIT OF STATE AND LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS WITHOUT ANY
INTERRUPTIONS OR DELAYS AND THIS
IS A TESTAMENT TO THE WORK AT
EACH AND EVERY YEAR WE EMPLOY.
AND THE LEADERSHIP OF HER FOR.
THIS CONCLUDES MY PREPARED
REMARKS I'M AVAILABLE FOR ANY
QUESTIONS THAT YOU MAY HAVE.
THANK YOU FINANCE. GOOD
AFTERNOON AGO CRYSTAL DEPARTMENT
FINDING HI HOW NO ADDITIONAL
STOMPED WITH PREVIOUS- SPEAKERS
WITH BUT I AVAILABLE DONT ANSWER
AND MEMBERS HALF THE YOU SOME OF. TO THANK MISTER CHAIR- JUST
APPRECIATE A THE- ALL THE CALL
FROM ALL THE PER HAS. LET ME
JUST SAY THE MISS MILLER.
MADURO'S- WILL REALLY REALLY DO
. YOUR HARD I KNOW THAT. WHEN
YOU TOOK OVER THE DEPARTMENT-
THERE WAS DEFINITE ISSUES TO
HEAR. ABOUT THE PROGRESS THAT
YOU MADE TO USE MADE SO FAR WITH
EXISTING STAFFING AND WITH- YOU
KNOW DURING A PANDEMIC OF THE
LAST TWO YEARS. VERY PROUD THAT
IT- FURTHER. AS WELL AS AB ONE
THIRTY ONE SO REALLY DO
APPRECIATE- YOUR WORK TO MAKE
THE AGENCY MORE TRANSPARENT-
MORE OPEN AND ALSO JUST-
PROVIDING FASTER. AND STRONGER
CUSTOMER SERVICE SERVICES SO
THANK YOU I'M I DID HAVE A
COUPLE QUESTIONS FOR MISS- MISS
FLEMING. SO CAN CAN YOU WALK-
WALKTHROUGH FOR THE FOR ELECTED-
YOUR FOR BOARD MEMBERS HOW HOW
MANY STAFF DO THEY HAVE EACH I
BELIEVE IT'S FOR. CURRENTLY
THANK YOU- ASSEMBLYMEMBER TING
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO RESPOND
ARE CURRENTLY ARE UP FOR
EQUALIZATION DISTRICT MEMBERS
HAVE A DISPUTE EXEMPTS POSITIONS
CLASS FOR A RANK AND FILE
EMPLOYEES FOR A TOTAL OF SIX
EMPLOYEES PER MEMBER. GOT IT
THANK YOU I THINK IT CAN YOU
JUST TERM WALK THROUGH THEIR-
THEIR DUTIES AT THIS POINT IN
TERMS OF- WHAT THEIR DAY TO DAY-
SORT OF. BROAD BRUSHSTROKES
DUTIES ARE. ABSOLUTELY SO I
THEIR PRIMARY RESPONSIBILITY AS
THE ELECTED BOARD- REPRESENTING
APPROXIMATELY A TEN MILLION
BECAUSE THAT DISTRICTS ANY
CONVERSATION DISTRICT OF TEN
MILLION OUR CONSTITUENTS- EACH
OUR PRIMARY RESPONSIBILITY IS
THE OBSERVATORY FUNCTION ALONG
WITH THE OVERSIGHT FUNCTION FOR
THE PROPERTY TAX ALCOHOLIC
BEVERAGE TAX AND TAX AND
INSURANCE PROGRAM SO SITTING AS
THE BOARD- THEY ARE HEAVILY
INVOLVED IN THE- POLICY MAKING
PROCESS. APPROVING AND REVIEWING
ON THE RGULATIONS APPROVING AND
REVIEWING FORMS AS WE ON THE
COUNTY ASSESS PROPERTIES LEVELS
INTERACT WITH THE UP FIFTY
COUNTY ASSESSOR'S SO THEIR ROLE
IN TERMS OF DAY TO DAY IS TO
ALSO ENGAGE WITH TAXPAYERS WILL
REACH OUT TO THEIR OFFICE IS ON
A PRETTY REGULAR BASIS. I'M TO
HAVE MORE LOCALIZED OF QUESTIONS
OR ISSUES THAT THEY NEED
ASSISTANCE WITH AND PARTNER WITH
US ON A REGULAR BASIS TO LOOK AT
OUR A BROAD RANGE OF MATTERS
IT'S RELEASED WITH SYSTEM
TAXPAYERS BE MORE AND FARMS AND
AWARE OF THE OUT OF THE TAX
POLICIES- AND THE BENEFITS THAT
THE- THE CITIZENS ARE ENTITLED
TO- THEY ALSO REVIEWED JUST TO
MAKE SHORT OF THE ORGANIZATION
IS OPERATING EFFICIENTLY.
ESPECIALLY AFTER THE AB ONE OH
TWO TWENTY SEVENTEEN LEGISLATION
ARE INTERESTED IN MAKING SURE
THAT WE'RE MODERNIZING- WORDS
ARE IN TERMS OF TECHNOLOGIES
PROCESS THESE EXCEPT FOR A ARE
ALSO TAKING A LOOK AT EVERY
OTHER FISH AND SEE- INCLUDING-
YOU KNOW. ANYTHING THAT WE'RE
DOING WITH OUR WEBSITES EXCEPT
FOR FURTHER THEIR VERY INVOLVED
WORKING WITH THE I. FIFTY COUNTY
ASSESSOR'S EACH EACH
EQUALIZATION DISTRICT MEMBER HAS
A DIFFERENT CONFIGURATION OF A
COUNTY SUCH AS THAT THEY WORK
WITH BUT THEY PARTNER HAPPILY
THERE- TO TAKE A LOOK AT- YOU
KNOW WHAT ARE SOME OF THE OTHER
THINGS THAT ARE NEEDED AS WE
MODERNIZE OUR PROPERTY TAX
SYSTEM. FOR EXAMPLE WE HAVE
RECENTLY HAD A NUMBER OF
HEARINGS- UNDER A CODE IN THE
STATE HOME THERE WAS A
SIGNIFICANT IMPACT TO THE
COUNTIES- SPECIFICALLY. LIKE
ASSESSMENT APPEALS BOARD FOR
EXAMPLE AND THE BOARD WAS. I'M
VERY. IN PROVIDING. TO BRING ALL
OF THOSE PARTIES. TO ENGAGE AND
STUDIES TO EXAMINE WHAT MIGHT BE
SOME GAPS ARE. TO GIVE US AN
OPPORTUNITY AS AN AGENCY TO SEE
WHAT WE COULD DO TO IMPROVE
THOSE PROCESSES AGAIN FOR.
MAKING SURE THAT WE HAVE SOME
CONSISTENCY IN THE STATEWIDE
MINISTRATION THESE PROGRAMS. I
HOPE THAT ANSWERS YOUR QUESTIONS
ARE. YES THANK YOU SO ON GO GO
BACK TO I THINK YOU'RE TO. WHERE
YOU STARTED WAS THERE I DO GOOD
I MEAN SOUNDS LIKE THEIR PRIMARY
RESPONSIBILITY. A SIMILAR TO THE
PASS IS REALLY THEIR
ADJUDICATORY- FUNCTION AND THEIR
THEIR BODY AS- A HEARING-
HEARING APPEALS IS THAT CORRECT.
IT OF THE SIGNET PORTION OF THE
RESPONSIBILITY CERTAINLY NOT THE
ONLY OF COURSE. AND GOOD
GOVERNMENT HOW MANY ARE. YOU
KNOW HOW HOW HOW MANY HEARINGS
DO THEY HAVE ANNUALLY. ARE
CURRENTLY WE ARE OBLIGATED BY
STATUTE TO HAVE AT LEAST- ONE
HEARING A MONTH SO WE HAVE
TWELFTH- THERE ARE OCCASIONS
WHEN WE HAVE AN INCREASED NUMBER
OF HEARINGS. ARE DEPENDING ON
THE ISSUE SOME DAYS SOME OF THE
HEARING STARTS TWO DAYS A MONTH-
BUT WE ARE WE HAVE- HEARINGS
EVERY MONTH. GOT IN CAN BE CAN
YOU TELL ME DURING THEM AMONG
THE THIRD DURING A GIVEN YEAR
HOW MANY. CASES ARE PETITIONS
THEY WALL HERE. HI CAL SEASON
PRIMARILY IN THANK YOU SIR AGAIN
FOR THAT QUESTION RPL SEASONS AS
PRIMARILY COVERED IN THE- THE
OCTOBER OF THE APPEAL PROCESS IS
A LOT LONGER THAN THAT. BUT IN
TERMS OF SCHEDULING THOSE ITEMS
BEFORE THE BOARD IS TYPICALLY
THE FOURTH QUARTER OF THE YEAR
BETTER HEARING MOST OF THE
APPEALS ACTUAL APPEALS- BUT
THERE ARE ALSO- AND NOT
APPEARANCE A TRIBUTARY MATTERS
THAT ARE BROUGHT TO THEM. I
FREQUENT THROUGHOUT THE YEAR
WHERE SOME TAXPAYERS MAY WANT TO
COME AND REYES ANYBODY ISSUES.
AGAIN IN ADDITION ABOUT IN
ADDITION TO THE OBSERVATORY
THERE ARE THERE INVOLVED INRULE
MAKING ACTIVITIES AND OVERSEEING
THE- SO THERE IS A WAVE AT THAT
THEIR COUNTY ASSESS PROCESS AND
THE STATUS AS PROCESS HE'S-
ADVISED. TO DISTINCT OUR LIFE
CYCLES AND SO THERE'S WORKLOAD
ASSOCIATED WITH THAT THROUGHOUT
THE YEAR. I DIDN'T HEAR A NUMBER
FROM YOU. AND OF THE NUMBER OF
MEETINGS OR-NO YOU HEARD DID
YOU STATE OF THE NUMBER MEETINGS
JUST- MANY. IMMIGRATION
QUESTIONS PART. DO HEAR ON IN A
TYPICAL THINK THAT'S- THANK YOU
ALL FOR THIS LAST YEAR I THINK
WE'VE HAD- INTRODUCED TOTAL
WORKLOAD WE PROBABLY BROUGHT
BEFORE THE BOARD- PROBABLY THREE
OR FOUR ACTUAL BUT THAT DOES NOT
REFLECT THE ACTUAL WORKLOAD
RELATED TO THE APPEALS. BECAUSE
THERE ARE A NUMBER OF APPEALS
GOING TO THE APPEALS PROCESS
THAT ARE- EFFECT WILL BE
ADMINISTERED AT AND OFFICIALLY
MINISTER CHRISTOS WORK. SO WE
MIGHT HAVE AT ANY POINT-
ANYWHERE BETWEEN TWENTY TO
THIRTY APPEALS ARE PER YEAR. ALL
OF THOSE CASES ARE POTENTIAL-
ITEMS THAT COULD COME BEFORE THE
BOARD OKAY SO YOU SEE YOUR THE-
WHAT WE ARE TWITTER. DESCRIBING
TO ME IS THE STAFF. WORKS FOR
THE BOARD IS WORKING ON TWENTY
TO THIRTY. HILLS BUT THE BOARD
MEMBERS THEMSELVES ARE JUST
HEARING ABOUT THREE TO FOUR
APPEALS A YEAR. I'M SO IN RECENT
HISTORY THAT SPEND THE WORKLOAD-
AND AGAIN BUT AT THE TIME THAT
THE APPEALS ARE THE PETITIONS
ARE ARE APPROACHING US AT THAT
POINT- ASSEMBLY MEMBER THING WE
WOULDN'T KNOW HOW MANY ARE
ACTUALLY GONNA SHOW SO WE DO
PROCESS ALL OF THOSE WITH THE
POTENTIAL OF THE COULD BE COMING
BEFORE THE BOARD. BUT THE
WEATHER'S A SIGNIFICANT PORTION
OF THE WORKS- THAT'S HANDLED BY
THE STAFF NOT PROPERLY SO. OKAY
BUT I JUST DON'T UNDERSTAND WHY
DO TWENTY FOUR. WHERE TWENTY
FOUR PEOPLE REQUIRED- TO ASSIST
ON FOR APPEALS A YEAR. IT'S
CURRENTLY AND STATUTES ARE. IN
TERMS OF THEIR TERRITORY
FUNCTION. SO THAT'S THEIR
RESPONSIBILITY LIKE THIS BY THE
BY THE STAFF. I UNDERSTAND THE
CONCEPT. SO I APPRECIATE THAT SO
THE STAFFING LEVELS- AND I WOULD
ENCOURAGE- AND INVITES AT THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE AND THE
LEDGE ON US OFFICE TO
PARTICIPATE IN THIS PORTION OF
THE DISCUSSION THERE WAS IN THE
TWENTY EIGHTEEN TIME FRAMES HER
ARM AFTER THE TWENTY SEVENTEEN
LEGISLATION WHERE THERE WAS A
STUDY DONE BY THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE THAT IT TOOK THE
OPPORTUNITY WHEN THE HIGHER
BOARD THAT CONSISTED OF A TWELVE
POSITIONS FOR EACH MEMBER.
ARMINA FINANCES A PART OF A
LETTER PROCESS EXAMINES THE
WORKLOAD AND THE NUMBER OF
VACANCY ON THE NUMBER OF
POSITIONS IN EACH MEMBER'S
OFFICE- BASED UPON THE
RECOMMENDATIONS FROM BOTH THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE AND L. A.
O. THE NUMBER THAT WAS
DETERMINED AND APPROVED IN
STATUTE- ENDED UP WITH A
REDUCTION FROM TWELFTH.
POSITIONS PER MEMBER TO SIX. AND
SO THAT'S THE NUMBER THAT-
BROUGH THE STATUTE WE ARE
WORKING WITH CURRENTLY DOES
MISTER HILL WANNACRY ON WHETHER
HE THINKS IT'S A- IT'S OUR- GOOD
USE OF TAXPAYER. TO HAVE- FOR
BOARD MEMBERS AND TWENTY FOUR
STAFF WORKING ON FOUR FIELD
HERE. NOT WORKING ON THE TO HEAR
FOUR PILLS A YEAR. MISTER HELP
THANK YOU RYSTAL THE DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE- AS MISS FUNDING
INDICATED WE DID DO A STUDY IN
TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN. IT WAS A
STAFFING STUDY REQUIRED AB ONE
OF TWO TO GET A BETTER IDEA AS
TO THE STAFFING RESOURCES ARE
APPROPRIATE FOR THE REDEFINED
BORDER EQUALIZATION AND THEIR
NEW MISSION. AND AS A RESULT OF
THAT STUDY WE INITIALLY FOUND
THE NEED FOR- TWO SIX
DEPOSITIONS AND FIVE CIVIL
SERVICE POSITIONS. AND UPON
FURTHER OR WORK FOR THE
LEGISLATIVE PROMPT PROCESS AND
WORK WITH LEGISLATIVE ANALYST
OFFICE WE STUMBLE UPON A FINAL
NUMBER ATKINS FUNDING INDICATED
OF. TWO EXAMPLES WERE SPECIFIED
IN THE STATE CONSTITUTION AND
THEN O CIVIL SERVICE STAFF. AND
WE HAVE NOT REVISITED THE-
STOPPING STUDIES SINCE TWO
THOUSAND AND EIGHTEEN BOTTOM.
ARE STANDING AT THE POINT IN
TIME WHEN WE DID THAT WAS THAT
WAS APPROPRIATE LEVEL. OF
STAFFING BASED ON ANTICIPATED.
BUT THE BOARD MEMBERS WOULD. IT
MISTER IN TWENTY EIGHTEEN WILL
INTO THE WORKED- WELL THE
INTEREST WORK WAS BASED ON. THE
NUMBER I CAN'T I'M SORRY IT'S
BEEN SEVERAL YEARS SINCE WE DID
THE STUDY BUT- IN ANTICIPATED
APPEALS AND THEN THERE'S ALSO
OTHER FACTORS LIKE- IN
RECOGNITION OF THE FACT THAT
THESE ARE CONSTITUTIONAL
OFFICERS EACH FROM HAVE TEN
MILLION APPROXIMATELY
CONSTITUENTS. WE NEED TO WORK AT
THEIR CONSTITUENTS ON ON MATTERS
OF- JUST CONSTITUENT
CORRESPONDENCE TYPE ISSUES- SO
THERE WAS THE TOTALITY OF THE
APPEALS WORK LOAD. THE TASKS AND
HERRON AND- HELPING TO
ADMINISTER THE BOARD OF
EQUALIZATION AND THEIR TASKS AND
ALSO HANDLING CONSTITUENT WORK
LOAD THAT WE'VE SETTLED UPON
BEYOND. TO EXEMPTS YOUNGER FOR
CIVIL SERVICE POSITIONS. BUT NOW
THAT THE APPEALS WORKLOAD IS
DOWN TO FOR A YEAR WHEN I THINK
FOR A MONTH PERCENT FOR THE
ENTIRE YEAR- THAT SEEMS TO
PROBABLY BE AN APPEALS WORKLOAD
THAT PROBABLY WAS MUCH LOWER
THAN WE HAD ALL ANTICIPATED IN
TWENTY SEVENTEEN OR TWENTY
EIGHTEEN- IT SOUNDS LIKE THE
WORK LOAD HOUSE OF WALL FROM
WHAT WE ANTICIPATED IT WOULD BE
FORTY YEARS AGO. AND OF COURSE
THE LEGISLATURE WISHES TO ON
INVESTIGATE THIS FURTHER THE
ADMINISTRATION BE HAPPY TO- WORK
WITH B. O. IN THE LEGISLATURE
TO- DETERMINE WHETHER OR NOT
THIS IS- STILL THE APPROPRIATE
LEVEL OF STAFFING GIVE EXISTING.
MEMBERS I APPRECIATE THAT MR
HELL BENT BIGGEST GO BACK TO
MISS MISS FLEMING SO THEN- SO
THEN THE- IMAGE IN THE FOURTH
QUARTER I ASSUME IS WHEN YOU'RE
HEARING THEM. THE HILLS LET'S
SAY WHAT WHAT'S HAPPENED IS THAT
THE OTHER THREE QUARTERS IN THE
TWELVE MEETINGS AND ANY OTHER
NINE MEETINGS OR HEARINGS SO I
APPRECIATE I APPRECIATE YOUR
QUESTION SIR AGAIN THANK YOU SO
I VALUE SETTING IS A SIGNIFICANT
PORTION OF THE WORK THAT'S DONE
SO- THAT OCCURS THROUGHOUT THE
YEAR ALONG WITH THE SALVATION
TAX RATES UP FOR OUR PRIVATE
RENTAL CAR TAX. AND ROADS- THERE
ARE A RANGE OF CONSTITUTIONAL
FUNCTIONS- AND ACTIVITIES THAT
OCCUR ON ARC AGENDA EVERY MONTH-
AGAIN FORMS OR SOMETHING AT THE
COUNTY LEVEL AND UPSKILL SIR
JUST TO CLARIFY IF I MAY THE
APPEALS PROCESS BASICALLY IN THE
PROPERTY TAX WERE PRIMARILY
BILLS FOURTH ORNAMENTS ARE
PRIMARILY THE STATE ASSESSED
APPEALS SO THAT'S ONE ASPECT OF
THE WORK IN THE COUNTY AS AS ONE
COULD APPRECIATE WORKING WITH A
FIFTY COUNT YES SIR OVER THE
STATE- THERE IS REGULAR WORKING
ISSUES THAT THE COUNTY
ASSESSOR'S RAISING ON A REGULAR
BASIS AND PART OF OUR WORK SO.
EXAM THE THINGS THAT I WAS
MISTER MISTER KIRSTEN'S PRESENTE
WAS THE PASSAGE IN THE AN
IMPLEMENTATION OF ABOUT NINETEEN
THAT HAS BEEN A SIGNIFICANT
PIECE OF WORK THAT DIDN'T EXIST
IN TWENTY. SEVEN BUT AGAIN
ASSEMBLY WORK. NOW OFFICE AND
TWENTY NO. AND SO THEY CAME ON.
OF THIS TIME THAT LED. WAS
PASSED AND SO ALL OF THE SIGNET
WORK AT THEIR- AND- TO LOOK AT-
HAS TO DO WITH THE PROP NINETEEN
IMPLEMENTATION IN THERE'S A
BROAD RANGE OF TAXPAYERS AS I'M
SURE- THIS BODY IS AWARE OF THAT
THEIR BROAD RANGE OF QUESTIONS-
AND WORK THAT'S NEEDED TO
SUCCESSFULLY IMPLEMENT THAT TAX
PROGRAMS. ARE BOARD MEMBERS ARE
FRONT AND CENTER AND
PARTICIPATING IN THOSE TAXPAYERS
BECAUSE TAXPAYERS ARE CALLING
THEIR- ELECTED REPRESENTATIVES
TO UNDERSTAND THAT. SELL FROM
THAT PERSPECTIVE HERE'S- THE
FIRST PART OF THE YEAR WE HAVE
THE IN TERMS OF COUNTY SAYS
THEY'RE LOOKING AT THEIR PROCESS
THEY'RE LOOKING AT. ARE AT EACH
WILL GET. EACH LEAN DATE DURING
AN EXAMINATION OF THE ITEMS THAT
ARE ON A ROLL WITH THEM BY THE
TIME WE GET TO THE SECOND THIRD
QUARTER WERE HEAVILY AS OF SEPT
FIRST AND SECOND QUARTER. WE'RE
DOING AN EXAMINATION OF THE ROLE
OF THE BOARD HAS TO ADOPT THAT-
BURKE ASSOCIATED FACT THAT IS
TAKEN UP ON THE AGENDA- EVERY
MONTH THAT I PRISON SUPPORT IN
TERMS OF. THE ANSWER ASSOCIATED
OUTBOARD ROLE A LOCAL PORK ROLL-
TAXES- SO THERE'S A BROAD RANGE
OF ACTIVITIES THAT HAPPENS ON A
REGULAR BASIS A LOT OF TIMES IT
HAS TO DO WITH FORMS AND JUST
EXACT PROCESS THESE. AREN'T THAT
GOOD COUNTY SAYS DRIVES A
SIGNIFICANT AMOUNT OF WORK THAT
IS IT'S A DIFFERENT BOTH HAVE A
SIGNIFICANT AMOUNT OF WORK- IT'S
JUST THE CYCLES FOR STATUS HAS
BEEN COUNTY ASSESSOR LITTLE BIT
THERE. BUT IT IS SIGNIFICANT
WORKLOAD- THE COUNTY ASSESSOR'S
BECAUSE THEY WERE GOING THROUGH
A PRETTY SIGNIFICANT INDUSTRY
CHANGE WERE ALL DEALING WITH
THIS ISSUE OF TRYING TO IDENTIFY
WORK FORCE. SO THE COUNTY
ASSESSOR'S RAISING A NUMBER OF
ISSUE- TO US PERCENT OR BOARD
LOOKING FOR YOU KNOW HOW DO WE
MAKE SURE AS WE'RE DOING OUR OUR
OUR SETTLEMENT. SURVEYS FOR
EXAMPLE ALL THAT WORK ARE WE
MAKING SURE THAT THERE'S
CONSISTENCY. SO THAT THERE'S
THAT FIRST AND SEE WHAT THE
MARKET IS CHANGING IN TERMS OF.
MAYBE SOME OF THE THAT MORE-
SEASONED AND EXPERIENCED
APPRAISERS AND ASSESSORS ARE
LEAVING HOW DO WE ENSURE THAT.
THOUSAND ON THE BOARD EXISTING.
ROLE IN ENSURE- THAT THOSE. ARE
INTACT AND SO BASED ON THE COST.
DUTIES PROVIDE. YOU KNOW. FOR
ALL OF THAT AND IN NUMBER OF
WAYS. I'M WORKING WITH THAT BOTH
COUNTY. TO HAS TO. I HOPE THAT
ANSWERS YOUR QUESTIONS OR THE
WORK OF THE STAFF. I THINK IT
WAS FROM IT WAS A OTHER FOR.
COUNTY SAN VERY FAMILIAR WITH
THE BOARD DUTIES ARE REGARDS THE
COUNTIES- AND I THINK YOU'RE
RIGHT- YOU KNOW YOU DEFINITELY
HAVE LAWYERS ON THIS. WHO ARE
INSTRUMENTAL IN PROVIDING
GUIDANCE YOU DO HAVE STAFF
MEMBERS WHO REGULARLY ATTEND OUR
CONFERENCES AND REGULAR- YOUR
LEADERS AND EXPERTS AND
OBVIOUSLY YOU MENTIONED THE-
SURVEYS OR YOU KNOW WE THINK OF
THEM AS AUDITS BUT HE SURVEYS
THAT YOU DO REGULARLY- BUT THOSE
ARE THE- THE STAFF FUNCTIONS- IT
DOESN'T SEEM. THAT THE BOARD
MEMBERS- TRADITIONALLY WAR EVER
VERY MUCH INVOLVED VERY
SPECIFICALLY- AND ANY OF THOSE-
PARTICULAR ITEMS OBVIOUSLY I
MEAN THAT THAT THAT THE LONG
HISTORY WITH THE BOARD TO
RESCIND THEIR IN THE
CONSTITUTION AND- THE REASON THE
ASSESSORS ARE ELECTED OF. BILLS
YOU KNOW FOR THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA EVERY SENSE WAS
ELECTED IS BECAUSE OF ALL THE
SCANDALS WE HAD OVER A HUNDRED
YEARS AGO AROUND PROPERTY TAXES
AND- TO HAVE A SIGNIFICANT
NUMBER OF CHECKS AND BALANCES.
AND TO REALLY PROVIDE OPENNESS
AND TRANSPARENCY UNFORTUNATELY
PRIOR TO TWENTY SEVENTEEN AND I
THINK YOU HEARD OR LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST SORT OF- REFER TO THAT-
THE BOARD INSTEAD OF BECAUSE OF
BEING A BEACON OF OPENNESS AND
TRANSPARENCY AND REALLY-
PROVIDING I THINK WITH THE
VISION WAS WHEN IT WAS CREATED
OVER A HUNDRED YEARS AGO- REALLY
FELL INTO MATT. SAID PROPS THAT
THEY WERE CREATED TO SOLVE SO-
TO ME IT'S UNFORTUNATE THAT.
WITH THE REDUCE DUTIES- THIS THE
STAFFING LEVELS ESPECIALLY FOR
THE FOR THE FOUR BOARD MEMBER
SEEMS PRETTY- WITHOUT- PRETTY
OVERSTAFFED- I ASSUME THAT AGAIN
THAT THE DUTIES OF THE INTERNAL
STAFF SEEM YOU KNOW PROBABLY
ARE. ARE CONTINUE TO BE
APPROPRIATE BUT AT LEAST FOR THE. FOR ELECTED BOARD MEMBERS ARE
PROBABLY IS IT'S TIME TO TAKE A
LOOK- HELLO VIEW. AND TO REALLY
TRULY WHAT THERE IS TO A MORE.
EFFICIENT USE OF GOVERNMENT
DOLLARS AND THERE'S A BETTER WAY
TO REALLY SPEND- OUR GOVERNMENT-
YEAH ARE ARE REALLY GOVERNMENT
PRIORITIES ESPECIALLY AT A TIME
WHEN. WE'RE REALLY LOOKING OUT
OF A WIDE VARIETY OF- THINGS IN
OUR BUDGET SUB- WITHOUT THING IF
I MAY. ASSEMBLY EMBER TEAM IF I
MAY RESPOND TO THAT- AND I DO
APPRECIATE COMICS. AND YOUR
EXPOSURE I STARTED WORKING AS A
DEBATE BUT OKAY YOU CAN RESPOND.
OKAY THAT'S DOT DOT DOT
INTENSELY BAY BUT DECIDED
CLARIFY I'M JUST LISTENING TO
AND AGAIN HAVING BEEN THERE
BEFORE DURING AND AFTER THE
LEGISLATION MY DIRECT EXPERIENCE
AND OBSERVATION IS THAT WHEN WE
HAVE WHAT WE REFER TO SIR S. B.
O. IN ONE .ORG. WE HAVE AS WE'VE
HEARD IN TODAY'S HEARING WE HAD.
OVER THIRTY TAX PROGRAMS
INCLUDING. INCOME TAX CORPORATE
TAX AND THE SALES AND USE TAX.
AND SO STUDENTS TO BE FRANK- THE
RANGE OF ISSUES RELATED TO THOSE
OTHER TWO TAX PROGRAMS THAT ARE
NOW- ADMINISTERED BY C. HFA.
THOSE ARE KIND OF THE VERY-
DEMANDING ERY VERY DAILY ACTIVE
OPERATIONALLY ACTIVE. TAX
PROGRAMS BECAUSE OF THE REVENUE
GENERATION. WHEN WE LEGISLATION
WAS PASSED IN TWENTY SEVENTEEN
IT DID REDUCE THE SCOPE OF THE
TAX PROGRAMS. BUT IT ALSO ALLOW
THE BOARD TO REALLY DO AS A
DEFINITE DRILL DOWN CLOSER
EXAMINATION OF PROPERTY TAX
WHICH QUITE FRANKLY SIR OVER THE
YEARS. HAD NOT WITH THE PRIOR
BOARDS RECEIVE THE SAME LEVEL OF
ATTENTION BECAUSE THEY HAD ALL
OF THE BAD THE OTHER SEXY TAX
PROGRAMS IF YOU WELL. I ONE
THOUSAND USED TAX PRIMARILY IN
INCOME TAX SO WHAT'S THE
LEGISLATION PASSED IT REALLY DID
GIVE THIS BOARD AND STAFF AN
OPPORTUNITY. TO FOCUS ON
PROPERTY TAX AS THE PRIMARY TAX
PROGRAM AND IT'S THAT
EXAMINATION ABOUT VERY IMPORTANT
TAX PROGRAM ON BEHALF OF THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA. IS A CLOSER
EXAMINATION THAT PROGRAMMER THIS
BOARD HAS ENGAGED JOINT SHORT
THAT IT IS INVESTIGATING-
BECAUSE THEY A PRIOR BOARDS-
PRIOR TO AB WANT TO. DEFINITELY
PAID A LOT OF ATTENTION. TO SURE
THEY WORK IN GENERAL. ARE AND-
AND STAFF EXCEPT FOR THE FOR THE
OTHER PROGRAM THAT WERE DOT FOR
PROPERTY TAX. AND PAUL. WANTED
TO THAT HAS OUR SHIP IN FOCUS
PRIORITIES. IT IS THE PRIME TAX-
THAT THAT MOST OF OUR STAFF FOR
ALLOCATED AND SO THE BOARD HAS
BEEN VERY MUCH. A STRONG AS WITH
THE SITTING BOARD WITH REALLY
FOCUSING- ON ALL OF A. B. TWO B.
AB ONE OH TO ROLL OUT-
RESPONSIBILITIES- AS THE FIRST
ONE THAT IS FULLY AB WANT TO THE
PRIOR BOARD STILL HAD A FEW
RECALL A LITTLE BIT OF TWENTY
EIGHTEEN. THEY STILL HAVE SOME
SOME LEFTOVER APPEALS WORK SO
I'M JUST IT TO JENNIFER AND DID
TO REACH STATE AND TO CONCLUDE.
THIS PART IS FOCUSED ON PROPERTY
TAX BECAUSE IT HAVE BEEN- ALLEN
CONNECTED OVER THE YEARS BUT
CERTAINLY NEEDED MORE ATTENTION
WHICH WAS NOT GIVEN TO IT AND
IT'S DUE ATTENTION. WHEN WE WERE
FOCUSING ON THE OTHER PROGRAMS
OF THIS PORT IS BEEN VERY ACTIVE
IN A WIDE RANGE OF THOSE THOSE.
THOSE FUNCTIONS. CAN YOU ARM
TALK THE FOR BORDER TWENTY THE
HAVE ANY. PROPER TAX. PER TO BE
ON THE BOARD. THANK YOU HAVE A
COMBINATION PROPERTY TAX
EXPERIENCE IN OFFICES YES SIR.
CAN YOU EXPAND ON THAT. SO FOR
EXAMPLE- AS IN AND MISS COLLINS
DISTRICT FOR EXAMPLE IN DISTRICT
TWO- AND- SPECIFICALLY AND FOR
EXAMPLE DISTRICT THREE WHICH IS
A TINY ON VASQUEZ'S DISTRICT-
BOTH OF THOSE HAVE STAFF THAT
WORKED WITH US BEFORE- AND ALSO
HAVE LOCAL GOVERNMENTS PERRANCE
WHAT THEY'VE WORKED. VERY CLOSE
WORKING RELATIONSHIPS WITH THE
WITH THE COUNTY CITY AND COUNTY
GOVERNMENTS AND BOTH HAVE-
EXPERIENCE WORKING WITH THEIR OF
THEIR LOCAL- COUNTY ASSESSORS-
AT AND K. THE REPRESENTATIVE
SALT FROM HIS CALLING FOR
EXAMPLE AS I'M SURE YOU KNOW
WORKS VERY CLOSELY WITH THAT
WITH THE CURRENT ASSESSMENT THE
PRIOR ASSESSOR CARMEN CHU.
SIMILARLY MISTER VASQUEZ WORKED
CLOSELY WITH THAT WHAT'S THE
HOTTEST L. A. COUNTY ASSESSOR
JEFFREY PRANG- SO THEY ALSO
INCLUDE STAFF SIR THAT CONTINUED
WITHIN THE RANK AND FILE STAFF
AND SOME OF. THE EXEMPTS STAFF
ALSO. MY QUESTION WAS AND THERE
ARE NO. OF PROPERTY THE WITHOUT
UP NOT TO MY KNOWLEDGE TO ANY OF
THE FOUR. ELECTED MEMBERS HAVE
ANY- WORK EXPERIENCE IN THE
PROPERTY TAX ARENA- AND I THINK
THAT WOULD BE OUR RANGE OF
EXPERIENCES THAT THEY HAVE THAT
THAT WHILE THEY MAY NOT HAVE THE
DEEP LEVEL OF EXPERTISE. ONE
THAT WAS MY QUESTION AS TO MY
KNOWLEDGE I DON'T BELIEVE ANY OF
THEM HAVE- PROPERTY TAX IT WORK
EXPERTS. OKAY THANK YOU SIR OKAY
SO YOU'RE NOT DISPUTING THAT-
BUT- I GOT GOING GOING BACK
AGAIN IF THE FIFTY EIGHT
COUNTIES THAT ARE REALLY IN
CHARGE OF DOING THE ASSESSMENT
AND THE COLLECTION OF PROPERTY
TAXES THE BELIEVES IS THERE TO
PROVIDE OVERSIGHT OUTSIDE OF THE
UTILITIES AND THE RAILROADS BUT
THEY'RE THERE TO PROVIDE THE
OVERSIGHT VERY DIFFERENT
FUNCTION THAN. WHAT YOU HAD FOR
YOUR OTHER INCOME TAXES IN YOUR
OTHER I USED TAXES WHERE THE
BOARD'S ACTUALLY COLLECTING
THOSE TAXES SO- I THINK IT DOES-
AS WE SEE NOW REALLY CALL INTO
QUESTION WHETHER OR NOT- THERE
REALLY IS A MUCH MORE EFFICIENT
WAY TO. TO DO THIS- THIS LAST
PART OF THE JOB WHICH THE BOARD
HAS BEEN CONSTITUTIONALLY AS YOU
SAID I TASK WITH WHICH IS REALLY
TO HEAR PROVIDE OVERSIGHT OF THE
FIFTY EIGHT COUNTIES AND MAKE
SURE THERE IS- THERE THE
PROPERLY ADMINISTERING PROPERTY
TAXES IN THOSE FIFTY ACCOUNTS
PROVIDING THAT OVERSIGHT SO.
AGAIN APPRECIATE. YOU BEING HERE
AND THANK YOU FOR YOUR COMMENTS.
I APPRECIATE THAT SIR I'LL MAKE
I THINK THE BOARD HAS
SIGNIFICANT VALUE AND- AND HAVE
A ROLE IN TERMS OF MAKING SURE
THAT THE- OTHER CITIZENS THAT
THEY REPRESENT FOR THEIR STATE-
I HAVE AN UNOFFICIAL TO ASSIST
WITH THAT PROCESS- BUT THANK YOU
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
COMMONSENSE.
ANY OTHER COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS
FROM THE DIESS MEMBERS FROM
DIED. AT MISTER NAZARIAN. THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR I THINK A I
THINK THE BUDGET CHAIR ASKED THE
GREAT QUESTIONS AND SO I DON'T
WANNA CONTINUE REPEATING SOME OF
THOSE QUESTIONS AND- MISS
FUNDING THANK YOU FOR BEING
HERE- OBVIOUSLY THIS IS THESE
QUESTIONS ARE. LONGSTANDING
ISSUES THAT AREN'T DIRECTED TO
YOU BUT TO THE AGENCY AS WELL-
THAT THE AGENCY AND WHOLE- I
JUST WANTED TO GO BACK AND ASK
SOMETHING VERY BASIC WHAT'S
GOING ON WITH THE BUILDING AT
THIS POINT. AND HAVE ALL THE
BOARD MEMBERS MOVED INTO THE
BUILDING AT THIS POINT. SO THANK
YOU FOR THAT QUESTION SIR- SO
CURRENTLY- ARE BOARD MEMBERS ARE
I'M HAVE TO ABIDE BY STATUTE OF
COURSE AS YOU KNOW SIR- THEIR
OFFICES EACH HAS AN OFFICE IN
THEIR DISTRICTS AND EQUALIZATION
DISTRICTS AND ALL OF THEM ALSO
HAVE OFFICES IN DOWNTOWN
SACRAMENTO AREA- IN TERMS OF THE
BUILDING YEAH WE IT'S NO LONGER
TERM ASSIGNMENTS ARE YOU
REFERRING TO THE FOUR FIFTY
INSTREAM STRUCTURE. THE BOARD OF
EQUALIZATION AND NO LONGER- IS
IN THE FOUR FIFTY AND ST THAT
BUILDING IS NOW FULLY OCCUPIED
BY THE- CD TFA- WITH THE
EXCEPTION OF ONCE WE RESUME
THEIR PUBLIC MEETINGS- WE STILL
HAVE THE BENEFIT OF HAVING OUR
OUR MONTHLY PUBLIC MEETINGS AND
THE- THE BOARD ONE FORMER BOARD
ROOM NOW REFERRED TO AS THE
AUDITORIUM- BUT WE NO LONGER
HAVE ANY AGENCY OR BOARD STAFF
INTO FOUR FIFTY N. STREET
LOCATION. AGAIN EACH MEMBER AS A
DOWNTOWN OFFICE AND DOWNTOWN
SACRAMENTO IN ADDITION TO ONE A
DISTRICT OFFICE AND THEIR- IN
THEIR RESPECTIVE. DISTRICTS SO
ARE ARE THEY DO THEY ARE THEY
ALL PHYSICALLY IN THE SAME
LOCATION. OR IN DIFFERENT
BUILDINGS. THEY'RE IN THEIR SACS
DOWN OFFICE THERE ARE TWO AND
BUILDING. SHARING A BUILDING AND
THE OTHER TWO WERE IN TWO
DISTINCT BUILDING SO WE HAVE
THREE SEPARATE LOCATIONS FOR
THEM. AND DOWNTOWN SACRAMENTO
AND OF COURSE IN THEIR
EQUALIZATION DISTRICTS THEY'RE
EACH. A SEPARATE AND DISTINCT
BASED ON GEOGRAPHY. AND ARE
THESE THREE BUILDING STATE OWNED
BUILDINGS OR ARE THEY PRIVATE
BUILDINGS. I ONE OF THEM IS A
STATE ON THE BILL AND SAN
FRANCISCO OFFICE OF STATE OUT
AND THE OTHER TWO- ARE OTHER
THREE ARE PRIVATELY OWNED AND
SACRAMENTO. SO ARE IN THE-
DOCKET NO I'M ASKING. THE
BUILDINGS LOCATED IN SACRAMENTO
ARE THEY ALL. ARE THEY ARE ARE
ANY OF THEM STATE BUILDINGS. OUR
MEMBERS ARE LOCATED- HAVE THEIR
OFFICES. NO SIR THEY ARE NOT. K.
THIS IS BEEN AN ONGOING ISSUE
WHERE. WE WERE THIS IS AT LEAST
IN THIS COMMITTEE WE'VE RAISED
THIS ISSUE ON MULTIPLE OCCASIONS
WHERE WE'VE ASKED WHETHER OR
NOT- THE BOARD MEMBERS WHO ARE
IN CHARGE OF OVERSEEING THE
TAXPAYERS DOLLARS. YOU WOULD
THINK WOULD BE A LOT MORE
CAUTIOUS IN HOW THE EXPENDITURES
DOLLARS AS WELL GIVEN ALSO SOME
OF THE SKETCH YOUR PRACTICES OF
SOME PREVIOUS PORT MEMBERS THAT
I'VE HAD IN THIS IN IN ON THIS
BOARD- AND SO YOU WOULD THINK
THAT. MESSAGE WOULD HAVE BEEN
LOUDLY HEARD THAT THEY WOULD OF-
CONSOLIDATED THEIR OFFICES INTO
A STATE BUILDING SO THAT THERE
WOULDN'T BE AN ADDITIONAL
EXPENDITURE- BUT INSTEAD THEY'RE
PAYING RENT OR OR LEASING SPACE
I'M ASSUMING IT'S PROBABLY SOME
KIND OF A LONG TERM LEASE AS
WELL. IN THREE DIFFERENT
SEPARATE BUILDINGS IN A CITY
WHERE THERE ARE. ANYONE WANNA
TAKE A GUESS HOW MANY STATE
BUILDINGS THERE ARE. A LOT QUITE
A FEW SPACES. AND SO I'M I'M
TRYING TO UNDERSTAND WHY HASN'T
THIS WHY HASN'T ANYONE BEEN
CONSCIOUS WHY HAVEN'T ANY OF THE
BOARD MEMBERS WHO ARE VOTED BY
THE PUBLIC BEEN CONSCIOUS ENOUGH
TO THINK ABOUT ACTUALLY
EXERCISING THEIR RIGHT AND THEIR
ABILITY OF MOVING CONSOLIDATING
THEIR OFFICES INTO ONE BUILDING.
AT LEAST MAYBE EVEN IF IT'S ONE
PRIVATELY OWNED BUILDING NOT A
STATE BUILDING AT LEAST MAYBE
THEY CAN TAKE ADVANTAGE OF- A
NEGOTIATING POWERS AND BE ABLE
TO LEAVE SOMETHING FOR- PROBABLY
SIGNIFICANTLY LESS THAN WHAT
THEY'RE PAYING NOW. IN THREE
DIFFERENT STEP IN THREE SEPARATE
BUILDINGS. WHY HASN'T THAT
HAPPENED SO FAR. SO IF- IF I MAY
OFFERS OR ONE OF THE THINGS THAT
WE CONSIDER. OUR LOOKING AT THIS
OF THE LOCATIONS ARE JUST A
COUPLE OF DIFFERENT LINES ONE
WAS BAGLEY KEENE- AND SO ANY
LOCATIONS THAT WE LOOK FOR FIRST
OF ALL WE LOOK FOR THE MOST COST
EFFECTIVE LET ME BEGIN THERE
ACTUALLY. I WOULD LOOK FOR THE
MOST COST EFFECTIVE BASED UPON
WHAT THE PRIOR- FOOTPRINTS-
TERMS OF THE SIZE OF THE OFFICES
BEFORE AND THE COST OF THOSE
LEASES. A SIGNIFICANT REDUCTION
IN BOTH SIDES OF THE OFFICE AND
THE AND THE LEAST COST I'M SORRY
SIR I DON'T HAVE AN EXACT NUMBER
IN FRONT OF ME BUT WE NEGOTIATED
THAT VERY CLOSELY WITH ALL
DEPARTMENTS FINANCE AND DGS TO
ENSURE THAT WE BECAUSE ALSO
RELATED TO THE REDUCTION IN
STAFF. WE ENSURE THAT WE WERE
APPROACHING AS AS COST
EFFECTIVELY AS WE COULD- WE DID
CONSIDER- AND YOU KNOW WHAT WE
COULD DO IN TERMS OF TRYING TO
FIND A LOCATION FOR ALL FOUR OF
THE MEMBERS THERE WERE SOME
CONCERNS WITH THE WHAT THE
OPTIONS WERE AVAILABLE AT THE
TIME WE WERE DOING THIS THIS
WORK. WE WERE LOOKING AT- THE
LOOK OUT OF THE FACILITY FOR
SECURITY REASONS BUT ALSO TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE RUN OUR NATION
OF ANY BAGLEY KEENE. THAT WE
DIDN'T HAVE YOU KNOW MEMBERS
ABANDONING SHIP OTHER AND JUST
CHATTING THINGS AND OR THEIR
STAFF UNFORTUNATELY THE TIME WE
WERE GOING THROUGH THIS PROCESS
WHILE THEY WERE A LOT OF A LOT.
OF STATE BUILDINGS AVAILABLE-
I'M TRYING TO LOCATE THOSE
WORKING WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF
GENERAL SERVICES AND SOMETHING
THAT'S THAT FIT THE NEEDS FOR
THE BOARD. THERE STEP. AND OTHER
RACIAL NEEDS THERE WEREN'T IN
THAT SUED SO OUR NEXT SIR WAS TO
JUST TAKE IT BACK OF THE NECK
BEST TO OPT WE DIDN'T SOME- SOME
PRIVATE SECTOR LEASES BUT THERE
ARE FOUR WAS SIR TO INSURE THAT
WE THE MOST EFFECTIVE AS
POSSIBLE SO THERE ARE A NUMBER
OF THEM THAT REALLY
SIGNIFICANTLY REDUCED SO WE HAD
FOR EXAMPLE ONE OF THE- ONE OF
THE OFFICES. THE PRIOR BOARD.
ONE MEMBER HAD THE ENTIRE
PHYSICAL SPACE. THAT WILL OFFICE
HAS BEEN SPLIT SO THAT TWO
MEMBERS ARE OCCUPYING THAT SPACE
YOU KNOW WITHOUT WITH SOME SOME
MINOR CONSTRUCTION THAT WAS DONE
ON IT. SO WE LOOK FOR EVERY
EFFICIENCY WITH THE INTENT OF
MAKING SURE THAT THE BOARD
MEMBERS OF THE BOARD MEMBERS
EXPRESSED THAT. FIND THE MOST
COST EFFECTIVE WAY THAT WE
POSSIBLY CAN TO MAKE SURE THAT
WE'RE NOT EXCEEDING IT BUT THEY
ALSO WANT TO MAKE SURE JUST FOR
COST EFFECTIVENESS WORKING THE
LEGISLATURE REGULATE. THAT THEY
HAVE CLOSE PROXIMITY ONTO THE
CAPITOL OFFICES SO- WE TRY TO DO
THAT ITCONSISTENT WITH ALSO
SERVE FRANKLY WITH YOU HAVE MANY
OF THE RECONCILE STAFF. THAT
WERE LOCATED IN THE SACRAMENTO
OFFICES WE TOOK INTO
CONSIDERATION ON ANY OTHER MOVES
THAT WOULD HAVE MOVED THEM YOU
KNOW WHAT HAD AN IMPACT FOR
STAFFING SO WAS ALSO. I'M SOME
THAT WAS SOME OF THE
CONSIDERATION WHETHER DOWNTOWN
STAFFING. SO WE LOOK FOR THE
MOST. EFFECTIVE AND THERE'S BEEN
A SIGNIFICANT REDUCTION IN OUR-
IN OUR LEASE COST AND PHYSICAL.
WE ARE STILL PAYING RENT AT THE
END OF THE DAY AND YOU'RE STILL
LEASING FROM THREE DIFFERENT. UP
PRIVATE ENTITIES INSTEAD OF
BEING LOCATED AT COLOCATED IN
THE STATE BUILDING- I STILL
DON'T UNDERSTAND WHY FIRST OF
ALL THE EVEN MOVED OUT OF- THE
FOUR FIFTY BUILDING. WHEN THE
REST OF THE STAFF REMAIN THERE-
EVEN WHAT IF THERE WERE
CHALLENGES WITH THE BUILDING.
WHY WOULD THE LEADERSHIP LEAVE
BUT THE REMAINING MEMBERS OF THE
STAFF STAY BEHIND IN THE
BUILDING IF THERE INDEED ARE
CHALLENGES WITH THE- WITH THE
BUILDING. AND FROM WHAT I
UNDERSTAND THERE WAS COMBUSTIBLE
FRACTURING AND THE WINDOWS WERE
SHATTERING NONE OF THE EXECUTIVE
LEVEL WINDOWS SHATTERED IT WAS-
EMPLOYEE LEVEL WINDOWS THAT WERE
SHATTERED. CARE TO COMMENT ON
THAT. WHAT WHAT I THINK- IT IN
THE CONTEXT OF WHAT WAS
HAPPENING AT THE TIME WE WERE
HAVING THE BUILDING ISSUES IT
WASN'T JUST THE BOARD MEMBERS
THAT MOVED OUT- THAT TO INCLUDED
A NUMBER OF STAFF THAT MOVED OUT
BECAUSE WE HAD NOT JUST THE-
BUILDING ISSUES WITH GLASS BUT
THERE ARE OTHER ISSUES THAT WERE
KNOWN THAT- THAT MOLD ECCENTRIC
SATCHER. SO THERE WAS A
SIGNIFICANT PERCENTAGE OF THE
ORGANIZATION THAT DID MOVE OUT
TO. A RITE AID LOCATIONS- I
REMEMBER SITTING IN A NUMBER OF
MEETINGS AT THE TIME WHEN ONE OF
THE THINGS THAT WE HAVE TO
CONSIDER WHAT THE BUILDING
INFRASTRUCTURE BILLION WEEKEND
AND CHALLENGED- SOME OF THE I
MEAN IT'S JUST SMALL THINGS FOR
EXAMPLE WHEN YOU HAD TO TAKE A
LOOK AT THE NUMBER OF PEOPLE IN
THE BUILDING BASED UPON THE AGE
OF THE OF THE- THE ELEVATORS FOR
EXAMPLE. WHEN YOU TO MAKE SURE
THAT THAT WAS ON THERE WAS ONLY
SO MUCH TRAFFIC GOING UP AND
DOWN ELEVATORS THOSE ARE SMALL
THINGS THAT SEEM INSIGNIFICANT
BUT WHEN YOU'RE WORKING WITH
PERSONNEL AND BUILDING ISSUES
THOSE ARE SOME OF THE EXAMPLES
OF SOME OF THE ITEMS ON THE
TABLE SO IT WASN'T JUST THE
BOARD MEMBERS THAT MOVED OUT
THERE ARE SIGNIFICANT- OTHERS
THAT THAT MOVED OUT- IN FACT THE
BOARD MEMBERS WERE MOVED OUT. TO
BE ABLE TO ACCOMMODATE MORE OF
THE STAFF THAT NEEDED TO BE
PHYSICALLY IN THE BUILDING
STYLE- TOO MUCH BEST OF MY
RECOLLECTION I DON'T BELIEVE IT
WAS THE BOARD'S GONNA WISH TO
MOVE OUT I THINK IT WAS JUST
PART OF THE DISCUSSION TO FREE
UP SOME SPACE. MISS ONE I DON'T
KNOW WHEN THE REST I WAS TOURING
THAT BY TOWARD THAT BUILDING ON
A COUPLE OF DIFFERENT OCCASIONS
AS A MEMBER OF THIS COMMITTEE
AND FROM WHAT I REMEMBER VERY
CLEARLY DISTINCTLY A LOT OF THE
STAFF WERE STILL IN THE BUILDING
AND NOT HADN'T MOVED- BUT BUT-
YOU ALSO MENTIONED ABOUT BAGLEY
KEENE. IF PORT FOR THE VIEWING
AUDIENCE I'D LIKE YOU TO EXPLAIN
WHAT THAT IS. SO THAT UP SO THAT
I CAN GET TO MY QUESTION. SO IN
JUST IN GENERAL HOW. SOME I
BASICALLY. IS THE- BILL STATUTE
OF ROLLS AROUND PUBLIC MEETINGS.
AND THE ISSUE AS RELATES TO
BOARD MEMBERS IS THAT WHEN I'M
BORED MEMBERS COME TOGETHER AS A
LECTOR BODIES- THEY WANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT ANY DISCUSSIONS OR
DECISIONS THAT ARE BEING MADE-
THAT WHICH- BE A PART OF THEIR-
OF THEIR AUTHORITY. THOSE
CONVERSATIONS DECISIONS AND
ACTIONS THE PUBLIC SHOULD HAVE A
RIGHT TO PARTICIPATE AND BE
EXPOSED TO THAT. SO WHAT YOU
WANT TO DO UNDER THE BACK WE CAN
ROLL BACK WE CAN ACT IS TO MAKE
SURE. THAT BOARD MEMBERS HAVE
SOME DEGREE OF SEPARATION UNTIL
THEY'RE IN THE PUBLIC MEETINGS.
AND SO WHEN THEY COME TOGETHER
IN A PUBLIC MEETINGS AND ITEMS
ARE PUT THE AGENDAS ARE
PUBLISHED THE PUBLIC IS INVITED
TO PARTICIPATE. I HAVE FULL
ACCESS TO ANY OF THE ACTIONS ARE
THE DISCUSSIONS THAT ARE
OCCURRING. THE CONCERN IS THAT
IF YOU HAVE THEM AND SOME OF THE
ISSUES THAT WE YOU KNOW TO. TAKE
CAUTION WITH BEFORE WHEN THEY'RE
ALL CALL LOCATED IN A BUILDING.
ONE OF THE ISSUES THAT WAS
RAISED BY LEGAL IT'S JUST THE
SENSITIVITY TO MAKE SURE THAT
THEY'RE NOT CO MINGLING
SOMEPLACE. AND POTENTIALLY
HAVING A CONVERSATION THAT SOME
COULD CONSIDER IS LIKE HEY OUR
HIGHLANDER THE BOARD MEMBERS ARE
NOT. HAVING AN EXCHANGE OF
INFORMATION OR DISCUSSING
SOMETHING THAT SHOULD BE
PUBLICLY. TO USE. THAT THIS
FUNDING DO YOU HAVE THAT LEGAL
DOCUMENT. I HAVE IT IN FRONT
HAVE THAT OPINION AVAILABLE- I
COULD WORK WITH AFTER TO
RETRIEVE INFORMATION I WANT TO
SEE THE ORIGINAL ONE NOT NOTHING
NEW I WANT TO SEE THE ORIGINAL
BECAUSE IF THAT'S THE CASE THEN
I THINK. I I'M WONDERING IF
WE'RE BREAKING ANY LAWS BY
HAVING EIGHTY ASSEMBLY MEMBERS
IN THE SAME BUILDING. I CAN TAKE
A LOOK WHAT'S THERE SO MY
EXPERIENCE WITH THE BOARD AS I
SAY HAS BEEN QUITE AWHILE SINCE
TWENTY ELEVEN. SOME OF THOSE-
HERE BUT I'LL CERTAINLY BE HAPPY
TO GO BACK AND WORK WITH LEGAL
SEE WHAT WE COULD RETREAT FOR
YOU. IS A PART OF HISTORIC
MATERIAL. SO YOU'RE SAYING THAT
BASED ON SOME A LEGAL OPINION
THAT THEY DECIDED TO CHOOSE TO
GO TO DIFFERENT BUILDINGS. I'LL
GO BACK AND GET THE INFORMATION
FOR YOU SO. BECAUSE IF THAT'S
THE CASE THEN THIS FLIES AGAINST
THE FACE OF EVERY LOCAL
JURISDICTION L. A. CITY COUNCIL
MEMBERS SHOULD AND ALL ALL
FIFTEEN SHOULDN'T BE LOCATED IN
THE SAME BUILDING THEY EVEN
HAVE. MORE RESTRICTIVE MEASURES
OF HOW NOT TO COMMUNICATE WITH
ONE ANOTHER- IT APPLIES TO EVERY
SINGLE JURISDICTION BELW THE
STATE LEVEL. AS WELL AS TO THE
STATE LEGISLATURE AS WELL SO I'M
I'M JUST I'M JUST TRYING TO
UNDERSTAND WHY THE BOARD OF
EQUALIZATION- HAS SUCH A SPECIAL
CIRCUMSTANCE. TO HAVE SUCH A
HIGH LEVEL OF EXPENDITURE IN
ORDER TO PROTECT ITSELF. AND THE
REST OF US DON'T. SO CARE TO
COMMENT ON THAT. WELL THANK YOU
FOR THE COMMENTS ARE AYE AYE. I
CAN GO BACK AND TAKE A LOOK AT
THE MATERIAL THAT WAS PROVIDED
ORIGINALLY AND SEE WHAT'S
AVAILABLE TO YOU- AGAIN SOME OF
THE DIFFERENCES IF I COULD JUST
CLARIFY YOU KNOW. WITHOUT GOING
INTO A DEEP DIVE DISCUSSION ON
BACK WE CAN PURCHASE THE BROWN
ACT WHICH GOVERNS THE LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS AND THE LEGISLATURE
DIFFERENT BRANCH OF GOVERNMENT
SOME SO THERE ARE DIFFERENT
APPLICATION OF THOSE RULES. ARE
SO HARD TO STAND THAT AND I
WANTED TO MAKE SURE THAT THAT'S
WHY I ASKED YOU TO EXPLAIN IT SO
THAT EVERYONE HEARS THAT NO I
GET THAT BUT I DON'T THINK THE
CHANGES ARE- WIDELY DIFFERENT
BETWEEN. US AS A LEGISLATIVE
BODY AND- AND THE BODY THAT YOU
REPRESENT YOU YOUR REPRESENTING
RIGHT NOW THAT THAT REQUIRES A
THEM TO BE IN A DIFFERENT
BUILDING- I'LL I'LL LET THANK
YOU VERY MUCH MANAGER FOR
ALLOWING ME THE OPPORTUNITY TO
ASK THESE QUESTIONS- I CAN GO ON
FOR SOME MORE BUT- AT THIS POINT
I'LL JUST TAKE A- TAKE A BREAK
AND I APPRECIATE YOU ANSWERING
THESE QUESTIONS. YOU'RE NOT THE
ONE WHO SHOULD BE IN THE LINE OF
FIRE BUT THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
BEING HERE WITH US. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER NAZARIAN OTHER
COMMENTS FROM DIETS. ARE
THINKING WE WANT TO. THANK THE
PANELISTS FOR. ISSUE NUMBER ONE.
WE ARE GOING TO GO BACK TO- TO-
THE VOTE ONLY CALENDAR CAN WE
HAVE ROLL CALL PLEASE. NAZARIAN
HI. WICKS. FIVE ZERO FIVE ZERO.
I WE'RE GONNA GO TO ISSUE NUMBER
TWO FOR THE VOTE ROLL CALL PLACE
. CORREA HI COOPER JACKIE THIS
ERIN WICKS HI FIVE ZERO K. THAT
IS FIVE ZERO AND WE ARE NOW
GOING TO CONTINUE ON TO ISSUE
NUMBER THREE MAKE IT BACK ON THE
AGENDA. WE ARE NOW ON ISSUE
THREE CANNABIS TAXES PROGRAM
ADDITIONAL AUDITORS. AND WE CAN
BEGIN. GREAT THANK YOU THANK YOU
SURE CARILLO- INDISTINCT
COMMITTEE MEMBERS ADJACENT
BALLOT- THE CFO CD TFA- AND I'M
JOINED BY NICK MADERA START
DIRECTOR AND SUZANNE BUELLER-
OUR HEAD OF OUR TAX AND FEE
DIVISION SO WE HAVE TO BE C.
P.'S- THE FIRST IS ON A
CANNABIS- AS PART OF PROP SIXTY
FOUR- CALIFORNIA VOTERS APPROVED
THE LEGAL SALE OF MARIJUANA FOR
RECREATIONAL USE STARTING IN
TWENTY EIGHTEEN. C. PROP SIXTY
FOUR ALSO CREATED TWO NEW TAXES
AND EXCISE TAX AND A CULTIVATION
TAX WHICH CD TFA IS RESPONSIBLE
FOR COLLECTING OVERSEEING- AND
ENFORCING. CDFA REQUESTS EIGHT
HUNDRED EIGHTY TWO THOUSAND AND
FISCAL YEAR TWENTY TWO TWENTY
THREE AND EIGHT HUNDRED FIFTEEN
THOUSAND IN FISCAL YEAR TWENTY
THREE TWENTY FOUR AND ONWARDS TO
HIRE FOR AUDITORS TO STRENGTHEN
OUR ENFORCEMENT CAPABILITIES- I
LIKE TO NOTE THAT THE REQUEST IS
FOR FUNDS ONLY NOT POSITIONS ON
THE DEPARTMENT WILL BE ABSORBING
THE POSITIONS ON WITH OUR
EXISTING VACANCIES- THE PURPOSE
OF THIS B. C. P. IS TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE CORRECTLY CHARGE- THE
SPECIAL FUND FOR AUDITS RELATED
TO- THE EXCISE AND CULTIVATION
TAX- WELL CANNABIS TAX REVENUES
HAVE STEADILY INCREASED FROM TWO
HUNDRED SIXTY MILLION IN FISCAL
YEAR EIGHTEEN NINETEEN TO OVER
SEVEN HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION LAST
YEAR. THEY'RE STILL ARE-
MATERIAL THEY'RE STILL AS MUCH
MATERIAL NONCOMPLIANCE. I'LL
GIVE YOU A COUPLE EXAMPLES AT A
HIGH LEVEL AND I CAN. CHOOSE AND
INDICATE THAT IF THERE'S
ANYTHING ELSE. MARIN SECTIONS
ARE HONEST THE DATE AND WE'VE
SEEN BASICALLY TWO LEGS OF
ISSUES THE FIRST IS AROUND
OWNERSHIP. WE'VE SEEN CASES OF
ENTITY FLIPPING OUT AS WELL AS
USE OF BURNER ACCOUNTS WHICH
MAKES IT CHALLENGING TO
IDENTIFY- OWNERSHIP IN TAX
LIABILITY. ON THE SECOND LIKE
IT'S AROUND RECORDS- THERE'S A
LACK OF BANKING RECORDS I BY
MANY CANNABIS BUSINESSES- AND
ALSO IN GENERAL AVOIDANCE TO
FORMAL RECORD KEEPING. IN TERMS
OF THE BENEFIT OF THIS REQUEST-
IT WOULD ENHANCE OUR ENFORCEMENT
CAPABILITIES- WHICH SHOULD
REDUCE OVERALL NON COMPLIANCE-
AND IN ADDITION GENERATED OVER
THREE MILLION DOLLARS. OF
ADDITIONAL REVENUES. WITH THAT
I'M HAPPY TO TAKE ANY QUESTIONS
. THANK YOU LETTER FROM THE OHIO. SEVEN KIRSTEN WITH THE L. A.
L. WE DON'T HAVE ANY- CONCERNS
WITH THE ITEM I THINK- WE I
STRUCTURE I CALL IT ITEM RATHER
THAN PROPOSAL SIMPLY BECAUSE OUR
UNDERSTANDING IS DUE TODAY SURE
OF CONTINUOUS APPROPRIATION
NATURE OF IT WE DIDN'T REALLY
SERVE EVALUATED AS A AS A-
PROPOSAL PER SE BUT WE DO
APPRECIATE THE OVERSIGHT
OPPORTUNITY AND- TRANSPARENCY ON
THE PART OF THE ADMINISTRATION
WE DO NOT OF CONCERNS. THANK YOU
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. GOOD
AFTERNOON AGAIN RESULTED OF ART
IN A FINANCE- WE'VE REVIEWED AND
WE SUPPORT THIS PROPOSAL AND I'M
AVAILABLE TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS MEMBERS MAY HELP. ANY
COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS FOR
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE.
CASCINA AND JUST ONE FOR ME WE
HAVE DISCUSSED THE CANNABIS TAX
FUND AT A PREVIOUS HEARING BUT
WANTED FINANCE TO DISCUSS AGAIN
WHO MAKES THE DECISIONS ON
ALLOCATION ONE AND IF THOSE
DECISIONS CAN BE CHANGED AND
THERE ARE CONCERNS AND IF SO HOW
- THE DECISIONS ON ALLOCATION
ONE ARE MADE BY THE
ADMINISTRATION PURSUANT TO THE
STATUTES THAT WERE ADDED BY THE
PROPOSITION THAT- CREATED. THIS
THIS MECHANISM THAT WERE
CURRENTLY OPERATING- IN THE
ADMINISTRATION HAS THE THIS THE
- STATUTE GRANTS ADMINISTRATION
THE DECISION ON THE
APPROPRIATION ALLOCATION OF
ALLOCATION ONE RESOURCES. UNTIL
JULY FIRST OF TWO THOUSAND AND
TWENTY EIGHT WHICH TIME THEY'LL
REVERT TO. A MORE TRADITIONAL
BUDGETING PROCESS IN WHICH THE
LEGISLATURE- THE ADMINISTRATION
PROPOSES IN THE LEGISLATURE
REVIEWS AND APPROVES. SO AGAIN
THE ADMINISTRATION MAKES THE
DECISIONS AT THIS POINT IN TIME
AND THAT WILL CONTINUE UNTIL
JULY FIRST OF TWO THOUSAND
TWENTY EIGHT. THANK YOU SO MUCH
APPRECIATE THAT- AND WE'RE GOING
TO HOLD THIS ITEM OPEN FOR THE
TIME BEING THAT CONCLUDES IN
ISSUE NUMBER THREE THANK YOU
VERY MUCH TO ALL THE PANELISTS.
WE'RE GONNA MOVE ON TO ISSUE
NUMBER FOUR. HOPE ACT THE
CALIFORNIA ELECTRONICS. EXCISE
EXCISE TAX- PLEASE BEGIN. THANK
YOU CHAIR CARILLO- SO IN OCTOBER
OF LAST YEAR SB THREE NINETY
FIVE PASSED WHICH CREATED A NEW
EXCISE TAX ON E. CIGARETTES
EFFECTIVE JULY FIRST- OF THIS
YEAR. TO FUND THIS NEW TAX
PROGRAM CD TFA REQUESTS ONE
POINT FOUR MILLION IN FISCAL
YEAR TWENTY TWO TWENTY THREE ONE
POINT TWO IN FISCAL YEAR TWENTY
THREE TWENTY FOUR. AND ONE POINT
FOUR IN FISCAL YEAR TWENTY FOUR
TWENTY FIVE AN ONGOING. THE
REQUEST WILL FUND A NEW
POSITIONS AS WELL AS EXISTING
STAFF TIME SPENT ON THIS NEW
PROGRAM- THE NEED THE REQUEST
WOULD BE FUNDED BY A NEW E.
CIGARETTE SPECIAL TAX FUND. AND
SINCE THIS IS A NEW TAX PROGRAM
AS PART OF SB THREE NINETY FIVE
THE GENERAL FUND LOAN THREE
MILLION DOLLARS TO THE NEW. U.
CIGARETTES SPECIAL TAX FUND. TO
PROGRAM THE NEW TAX PROGRAM INTO
OUR CROSS IT SYSTEM IT ALSO TO
DESIGN A NEW TAX RETURN- AND
REACH OUT TO TAXPAYERS THE THREE
MILLION DOLLAR LOAN WILL BE
REPAID WITH TAX REVENUES ON THIS
COMING FISCAL YEAR TWENTY TWO
TWENTY THREE. I'M TERMS OF
BENEFITS THAT WORK THE NEW TAXES
FORECAST TO GENERATE SEVENTEEN
MILLION AND ACCOUNTING TWO
THOUSAND TWENTY TWO FOR HALF
YEAR. AND THIRTY FIVE MILLION IN
TWO THOUSAND TWENTY THREE FOR
THE FULL YEAR. I WITH THAT I'M
HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS.
EXCUSE ME THANK YOU SO MUCH
LET'S HEAR FROM ALLEY A PLACE. A
SET CRISTINA L. A. WE HAVE NO
CONCERNS WITH THE PROPOSAL.
THANK YOU DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
. BRAZIL DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
TO SUPPORT THIS PROPOSAL AND ARE
HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS
THE MEMBERS CAN HELP. ANY
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE WITH
ANY COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS. OKAY
SEEN NONE. WE ARE GOING TO HOLD-
THIS ITEM OPEN FOR NOW AS WELL
WE'RE GOING TO MOVE THANK YOU TO
THE PANELISTS ON THIS PARTICULAR
ISSUE. WE ARE NOW GOING TO MOVE
ON TO ISSUE NUMBER FIVE EARNED
INCOME TAX CREDIT. FOSTER YOUTH
EXPANSION THE YOUNG CHILD TAX
CREDIT OUT REACH- LET'S BEGIN
OTHER GOING TO COME UP WITH.
WE'RE GOING TO. THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR COOLEY WHITE- DEPARTMENT
FINANCE ON STARTING WITH THE E.
I. T. C. FOSTER YOUTH EXPANSION
. I THIS PROPOSAL CREATES A NEW
ONE THOUSAND DOLLAR REFUNDABLE
TAX CREDIT- BEGINNING IN TAX
YEAR TWENTY TWENTY TWO FOR YOUNG
ADULTS AGE EIGHTEEN TO TWENTY
FIVE. WHO WERE IN THE FOSTER
SYSTEM AT ANY TIME AGE THIRTEEN
OR OLDER- THIS CREDIT IS MODELED
AFTER THE YOUNG CHILD TAX CREDIT
THE YOUNG CHILD TAX CREDIT WAS
ENACTED IN TWENTY NINETEEN AND
PROVIDES A FLAT ONE THOUSAND
DOLLARS TO FAMILIES THAT
OTHERWISE. QUALIFY FOR THE EITC
AND HAVE A CHILD AGE FIVE OR
UNDER. SIMILARLY THIS NEW CREDIT
WILL ALSO PROVIDE A FLAT ONE
THOUSAND DOLLARS TO YOUNG ADULTS
THAT OTHERWISE QUALIFY FOR THE
EITC THIS CREDIT IS INDEXED TO
INFLATION AND WILL PHASE OUT THE
SAME AS THE CURRENT YOUNG CHILD
TAX CREDIT. FOSTER YOUTH AGES
EIGHTEEN TO TWENTY ONE THAT ARE
TRANSITIONING OUT OF FOSTER CARE
SYSTEM AND TRIBAL YOUTH THAT ARE
UNDER THE STATE'S JURISDICTION
WOULD ALSO BE ELIGIBLE FOR THE
CREDIT. ADULTS THAT ARE RAISED
IN THE FOSTER CARE SYSTEM
GENERALLY SUFFER THAT WERE
RAISED IN THE IN THE FOSTER CARE
SYSTEM GENERALLY SUFFER
DISPROPORTIONATE LEVELS OF
ECONOMIC HARDSHIP AND POVERTY. A
FORMER FOSTER YOUTH IN THE
EIGHTEEN TO TWENTY FIVE YEAR
RANGE ARE PARTICULARLY
VULNERABLE POPULATION.
TRANSITION IN THE WORK FORCE
THAT COULD BENEFIT FROM THIS
MEANINGFUL CREDIT- THE CREDIT
ALSO ENCOURAGES TAX FILING WHICH
IS A KEY PART OF BUILDING
GENERAL ECONOMIC LITERACY. AND
COULD LEAD TO THE CLAIMING OF
OTHER FEDERAL AND STATE TAX AND
BENEFITS AMONG THIS POPULATION.
OF THE CREDIT WILL BE
ADMINISTERED BY THE FRANCHISE
TAX BOARD AND RICK REQUIRED DATA
SHARING WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF
SOCIAL SERVICES. AS THE ESTIMATE
IS THAT SEVENTY FIVE THOUSAND
INDIVIDUALS COULD POTENTIALLY BE
ELIGIBLE FOR THE CREDIT. AND
THEN AFTER COUNTING FOR TYPICAL
TAKE UP RATES AS WELL AS THE
INCOME REQUIREMENTS OF THE
COUNTY ITC. THE FISCAL COST OF
THIS PROPOSAL IS EXPECTED TO BE
ABOUT TWENTY MILLION PER YEAR.
AND AFFECT ABOUT TWENTY THOUSAND
INDIVIDUALS. WITH THEIR WOULD
YOU LIKE ME TO CONTINUE ON WITH
THE- THE OTHER ISSUES IN THIS-
ISSUERS ARE STOP THERE. LET'S
CONTINUE ON WITH THE OTHER
ISSUES PLEASE. OKAY SO THE YOUNG
CHILD TAX CREDIT- IS WAS CREATED
IN THE NINETEEN TWENTY BUDGET TO
HELP NICK NICK CHEUNG YOUNG
CHILDREN OUT OF POVERTY THIS
CREDIT IN MOST CASES OFFERS ONE
THOUSAND DOLLARS TO EVERY
HOUSEHOLD THAT QUALIFIES FOR THE
CARRIER TO SEE THAT HAS A CHILD
AGE FIVE OR YOUNGER THE CURRENT
OF THE YOUNG YOUNG CHILD TAX
CREDIT CURRENTLY REQUIRES
RECIPIENTS TO HAVE AT LEAST ONE
DOLLAR OF EARNED INCOME EARNED
INCOME IS INCOME FROM ALL
EMPLOYMENT INCLUDING WAGES
SALARIES TIPS AND OTHER
COMPENSATION. SELF EMPLOYMENT
INCOME IS CONSIDERED EARNED
INCOME FOR THE TWENTY TWENTY TAX
YEAR FOR ABOUT FOUR TWENTY
THOUSAND TAXPAYERS CLAIM THIS
CREDIT. SO THE FIRST COMPONENT
OF THIS PROPOSAL BEGINNING ITH
TAX YEAR TWENTY TWENTY TWO IT
REMOVES A ONE DOLLAR REQUIREMENT
ALLOWS ALLOWS HOUSEHOLDS WITH NO
EARNED INCOME OR NEGATIVE EARNED
INCOME TO CLAIM THE YOUNG CHILD
TAX CREDIT. IF THEY OTHERWISE
QUALIFY FOR THE COUNTY ITC- THE
YOUNG CHILD TAX CREDIT IS
DESIGNED TO ALLEVIATE CHILD
POVERTY RATHER THAN AS AN
INCENTIVE TO WORK AND THEREFORE
IT MAKES POLICY STEP. AND STICKS
THEM THIS BENEFIT FAMILIES WITH
NO INCOME TO ALLEVIATE CHILD
POVERTY. REQUIRING ARNIE'S
EARNINGS EXCLUDES PARENTS WHOSE
NEED TO CARE FOR THEIR CHILD
PREVENTS THEM FROM MEETING
MAINTAINING A JOB. AS WELL AS
THOSE THAT CANNOT FIND CHILD
CARE TO MAINTAIN A JOB. FAMILIES
WITH YOUNG CHILDREN HAT HAVE NO
INCOME ARE JUST AS DESERVING TO
RECEIVE THE YOUNG CHILD TAX
CREDIT IS FAMILIES WITH INCOME.
THIS EXPANSION OF THE YOUNG
<c.green>HILD TAX CREDIT IS EXPECTED TO</c>
REDUCE GENERAL FUND REVENUES BY
FIFTY FIVE MILLION DOLLARS PER
YEAR BEGINNING IN FISCAL TWENTY
TWO TWENTY THREE. AFFECT ABOUT
FIFTY FIVE THOUSAND HOUSEHOLDS.
THE SECOND COMPONENT OF THIS
PROPOSAL IN THE INDEXES THE ONE
THOUSAND DOLLAR YOUNG CHILD TAX
CREDIT FOR INFLATION. STARTING
IN TWENTY TWENTY TO TAX YEAR TO
PREVENT INFLATION FROM ERODING
THE VALUE OF THIS IMPORTANT TAX
CREDIT. FOR FAMILIES WITH YOUNG
CHILDREN. THIS CHANGE WOULD BE
CONSISTENT WITH THE HAVE A STATE
AND FEDERAL. EITC WHICH ARE BOTH
INDEXED TO INFLATION WOULD BE
ADMINISTERED. AS MENTIONED OVER
FOUR THOUSAND FAMILIES WITH
YOUNG CHILDREN WOULD BENEFIT
FROM THIS CHANGE AND THIS
PROPOSAL IS EXPECTED TO DECREASE
PERSONAL INCOME TAX REVENUES BY
NINETEEN MILLION IN FISCAL YEAR
TWENTY TWO TWENTY THREE. WITH
INCREASING AMOUNTS AND IN
SUBSEQUENT YEARS AS THE
INFLATION IS ADJUSTED- ARE
LASTLY WE HAVE THE- WE HAVE A
TEN MILLION DOLLARS IN THE
BUDGET THAT'S INCLUDED FOR OUT
REACH SO WITH THAT THAT
CONCLUDES MY REMARKS AND THEN
ADD I'M JOINED BY MY COLLEAGUES
AT THE DEPARTMENT FINANCES WELL
AS FRANCHISE TAX BOARD AND HAPPY
TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS. THANK
YOU FOR THAT LET'S GO TO THE
ALLEY- PLEASE. WEATHERFORD RAN
WHETHER FORD WITH THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE AND
WE DON'T HAVE ANY COMMENTS ON
THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSALS
REGARDING THE EARNED INCOME TAX
CREDIT AND CHILD TAX CREDIT
PROPOSALS. BUT WE'RE AVAILABLE
TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS OR WORK
WITH YOU AND YOUR STAFF ON AN
ANALYTICAL REQUEST MY HAPPENED.
THANK YOU LET'S HEAR FROM FTP
PLEASE. GOOD AFTERNOON. SO I
MEAN TO SAY THAT BEING TECHNICAL
ASPECTS OF THE CREDIT IF THERE'S
ANY QUESTIONS THAT IS ABLE AND
WILLING TO ASSIST. NUMBER SEVEN
. USE YOUR SELF- MY JAMIE HARRON
FRANCHISE TAX BOARD. INTIAL
OFFICER FRANCHISE TAX BOARD. SO
IN REGARD TO THESE TWO CREDITS-
AGAIN TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE ON
THAT CAN BE IS ONLINE THAT CAN
ASSIST BUT I'M GONNA TRY TO STOP
IT- ADDRESSING THE OUTRAGE TYPE
ORIENTED QUESTIONS THAT ARE
INCLUDED IN THE AGENDA SO- AS
YOU KNOW- AND OTHERS KNOW IT
WE'VE BEEN WORKING WITH FOR
ABOUT THE LAST YEAR PRETTY
HEAVILY AND REGARDS TO HOW CAN
WE ENHANCE OUTREACH HOW CAN WE-MAKE IT EASIER TO FILE- JANUARY
THIRD WE ISSUED A REPORT THAT
MANY FOLKS HAVE CONTINUED TO
READ THROUGHOUT THE MONTHS
FOLLOWING. IN REGARDS TO MANY-
INCENTIVES AND- EFFORTS THAT WE
COULD DO TO DO THAT- MANY OF
THOSE EFFORTS ARE ALSO RELEVANT
TO REACHING OUT TO FOSTER YOUTHS
WERE REACHING OUT TO THESE
INDIVIDUALS THAT DO NOT HAVE
ZERO INCOME BUT WHAT NOW FOR THE
FIRST TIME THE ELIGIBLE THOSE
CREDITS. SO- FOSTER YOU THE WE
ARE STILL WORKING ON SCHOOL.
WITH OUR PARTNER AGENCIES TO THE
US US ON HOW WE CAN
OPERATIONALIZE THIS. AND THAT
WOULD INCLUDE OUTREACH UNDER OUR
FEDERAL LAWS THAT PROHIBIT THE
DISCLOSURE OF THE NAMES OF THESE
INDIVIDUALS. SO I HAVE TO BE
CERTAIN I COULD NOT DO DIRECT
OUTREACH TO THESE INDIVIDUALS
AND WE ARE SEEING WHAT CBS
ASKING GENERAL. HOWEVER THE GOOD
NEWS IS THERE'S A LOT OF
ADVOCACY GROUPS THAT WORK WITH
THESE INDIVDUALS AND WE ARE
DEFINITELY GOING TO BE
LEVERAGING THEM TO MAKE SURE
THAT THEY'RE HELPING US-
ADVOCATE THAT THESE PROPOSALS.
EXISTS TO BEACH COSTS ARE YOU.
ON AND THAT HOW THEY CAN TAKE
ADVANTAGE OF IT SO- THAT IS
DEFINITELY A KEY STRATEGY THAT
WILL BE DURING THIS YEAR. LONDON
STRENGTHENING FOUR ZERO INCOME
INDIVIDUALS THAT WILL BE
ELIGIBLE POTENTIALLY FOR THE
FIRST TIME THAT THE SMALLER TO
BE INDUCTED. I'M FOR THE MOST
PART THOSE ARE INVISIBLE
INDIVIDUALS TO HAVE TO BE ON
BECAUSE THEY SIMPLY DO NOT HAVE
INCOME STREAM. THAT COMES INTO A
SUCH AS WAGES WHICH IS THE MOST-
CREDIBLE WAY THAT WE CAN
IDENTIFY INDIVIDUALS. HOWEVER
NOT TO BE I'M SITTING AND
WAITING AROUND FOR SOMETHING TO
HAPPEN MORE ALSO REACHING OUT.
TO DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL SERVICES
AND DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH CARE
SERVICES. TO SEE IF WE CAN
UNDERSTAND SOME OF THEIR
POPULATIONS THAT MIGHT FALL INTO
THIS GROUP. AND THEN ONE OF US
FROM THOSE RESPECTIVE THREE
AGENCIES REACHING OUT TO THOSE
FOLKS AT THAT POINT AS WELL.
AGAIN TO MAKE SURE THERE WERE
CUT ITS EXISTENCE- MAKE SURE
THERE WERE FEDERAL CREDIT I
THINK IT ALSO QUITE FOR. AND
THEN ALSO MAKE SURE THAT THEY'RE
AWARE OF HOW TO ENGAGE THREE TAX
PREPARATION SERVICE. VITA IN THE
EVENT THAT THE SERVICES. RUNNING
OUT. HERE REACHED OUT TO. SO I'M
WITH I DON'T HAVE ANSWER OTHER
SPECIFIC QUESTION YOU LET OUT.
IN ALL- ON BACKSHEET THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN MUCH
OF. LET'S GO TO WITNESS HERE IN
THE ROOM. GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM
CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
ALYSSA ANDERSON WITH THE
CALIFORNIA BUDGET AND POLICY
CENTER AND APPRECIATE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK TODAY-
FIRST OF ALL I WANT TO COMMEND
THE ADMINISTRATION FOR PROPOSING
TO AND EARNINGS REQUIREMENT FOR
CALIFORNIA'S YOUNG CHILD TAX
CREDIT. THIS WILL HELP MORE
FAMILIES WHO ARE WORKING HARD TO
RAISE THEIR CHILDREN MEET BASIC
NEEDS AND THIS IS ESPECIALLY
CRITICAL NOW THAT THESE FAMILIES
WILL BE DENIED THE FEDERAL CHILD
TAX CREDIT. BUT INCLUDING THESE
FAMILIES IN CALIFORNIA'S CREDIT
IS JUST THE FIRST STEP. THE NEXT
STEP IS MAKING SURE THOSE
FAMILIES ACTUALLY GET THE
CREDIT. THE CHALLENGES THESE
FAMILIES ARE REQUIRED TO FILE
TAXES. SO WHAT'S NEEDED TO HELP
FAMILIES GET THE CREDIT. FIRST
MORE FUNDING AND CONSISTENT
FUNDING TO COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS AND FREE TAX PREP
SITES BECAUSE IT'S CRITICAL THAT
FAMILIES LEARN ABOUT THE CREDIT
THROUGH TRUSTED MESSENGERS. WHO
CAN HELP THEM CLAIM THE CREDIT
FOR FREE. MORE FREE TAX PREP
MEANS MORE MONEY INTO FAMILIES
POCKETS AND MORE OF WHAT
CALIFORNIA SPENT ON TAX CREDITS
GOING TO FAMILIES INSTEAD OF FOR
PROFIT TAX PREPARERS. A SECOND
WAY CALIFORNIA CAN HELP FAMILIES
GET THE YOUNG CHILD TAX CREDIT
IS BY MAKING A SIMPLE CHANGE IN
STATUTE THAT WOULD ALLOW THE
DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL SERVICES
AND DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH CARE
SERVICES. TO IDENTIFY THE
SPECIFIC FAMILIES ENROLLED IN
SAFETY NET PROGRAMS WHO ARE AT
RISK OF MISSING OUT ON THE
CREDIT BECAUSE THEY DON'T FILE
TAXES. THEN THE DEPARTMENTS
COULD CONNECT THESE FAMILIES
WITH FREE FILING RESOURCES. THIS
COULD REACH TENS OF THOUSANDS OF
CHILDREN WHO BECOME ELIGIBLE FOR
THE YOUNG CHILD TAX CREDIT UNDER
THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL. DSS
RECENTLY CONDUCTED A SIMILAR
EFFORT AROUND FEDERAL STIMULUS
PAYMENTS THAT'S BEING EVALUATED
BY THE CALIFORNIA POLICY LAB IN
THE PEOPLE LAB TO SEE WHICH
OUTREACH STRATEGIES ARE MOST
EFFECTIVE. AND THAT COULD INFORM
HOW BEST TO REACH FAMILIES WHO
ARE ELIGIBLE FOR THE YOUNG CHILD
TAX CREDIT. ANOTHER IDEA FROM
CALIFORNIA POLICY LAB IS FOR
COUNTIES TO HELP DETERMINE
WHETHER THEIR CLIENTS ARE
ELIGIBLE FOR THE YOUNG CHILD TAX
CREDIT WHENEVER THEY RECERTIFY
ELIGIBILITY FOR A PROGRAM. THAT
MAKE APPOINTMENTS FOR THEM AT
FREE TAX PREP SITES. THIS IS A
BEST PRACTICE THAT WOULD
DIRECTLY CONNECT FAMILIES FROM
ONE SOURCE OF SUPPORT TO ANOTHER. IN THE CREDIT. FOR EXAMPLE
MAYBE FAMILIES WITHOUT EARNINGS
COULD CLAIM THE CREDIT WITHOUT
FIRST HAVING TO COMPLETE A
FEDERAL RETURN. THAT WOULD EASE
THE BURDEN FOR FAMILIES WHO HAVE
NO REASON TO FILE A FEDERAL TURN
NOW THAT THEY ARE SHOT OUT OF
THE FEDERAL CHILD TAX CREDIT. OR
MAYBE HAVE TO BE COULD PROVIDE A
SIMPLIFIED METHOD FOR FAMILIES
WITHOUT EARNINGS TO CLAIM THE
CREDIT SO THEY DON'T HAVE TO
WAIT THROUGH THE QUESTIONS ON A
FULL STATE RETURN THAT ARE
RELEVANT TO THEM. THESE ARE JUST
SOME IDEAS AND AS WE HEARD
EARLIER FTP HAS OTHERS AS WELL.
AND THE LAST POINT I WANT TO
MAKE IS THAT IN LOOKING AT HOW
TO GET THE YOUNG CHILD TAX
CREDIT. TO FAMILIES WITHOUT
EARNINGS. THERE'S AN OPPORTUNITY
TO TACKLE A MUCH BROADER
CHALLENGE. OF HOW TO PROVIDE
ECONOMIC RELIEF THAT REACHES
PEOPLE WHO DON'T HAVE EARNINGS.
AND ARE AMONG THOSE MOST IN NEED
OF SUPPORT RIGHT NOW. FOR
EXAMPLE THERE'S A LOT OF
INTEREST IN PROVIDING-
CALIFORNIANS ECONOMIC RELIEF IN
THIS YEAR'S BUDGET. AND PEOPLE
WITH THE LOWEST INCOMES ARE MOST
IN NEED. SIX IN TEN CALIFORNIANS
WITH INCOMES UNDER THIRTY FIVE
THOUSAND DOLLARS. REPORTED
STRUGGLING TO PAY BASIC EXPENSES
LAST MONTH. THE PROBLEM IS NOT
JUST. THE GAS BUT RISING FOOD
AND RENT AT A TIME WHEN MOST
PANDEMIC EIGHT HAS ENDED. SO
IT'S CONVERSATIONS AROUND
PROVIDING RELIEF CONTINUE IT'S
WORTH REFLECTING ON HOW
CALIFORNIA ACHIEVED A REALLY
INCREDIBLE FEET LAST YEAR.
GETTING RELIEF OUT TO MILLIONS
OF PEOPLE THROUGH THE GOLDEN
STATE STIMULUS AND PARTICULARLY
TARGETING MILLIONS OF KALYA TO
SEE RECIPIENTS. THAT WAS PAIRED
WITH GOLDEN STATE GRANTS THAT
REACHED MANY PEOPLE WHO DON'T
HAVE EARNINGS AND WOULDN'T HAVE
GOTTEN THE STIMULUS TO FTP.
THESE ARE PROVEN WAYS TO TARGET
RELIEF TO PEOPLE WHO NEED IT
MOST. AND THEY COULD BE USED%
AGAIN THIS YEAR. AND PERHAPS
EVEN BE EXPANDED TO REACH MORE
PEOPLE ESPECIALLY PEOPLE WITHOUT
EARNINGS. SO I THINK THESE ARE
QUESTIONS WORTH EXPLORING SO
THAT YOU CAN FURTHER DEVELOP
EFFECTIVE WAYS OF TARGETING
MEANINGFUL RELIEF TO AS MANY
CALIFORNIANS IN NEED AS
POSSIBLE. NOT JUST IN THIS
YEAR'S BUDGET BUT IN FUTURE
YEARS AS WELL. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
ANA HOW SUPPLIED WITH UNITED
WAYS OF CALIFORNIA AND
REPRESENTING THE CAL THE ATC
COALITION. WE ARE ENCOURAGED BY
THE INCLUSION OF TEN MILLION IN
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET FOR KELLY
A TO SEE OUT REGION FREE TAX
PREP GRANTS. HOWEVER WE STRONGLY
URGE THE LEGISLATURE TO INVEST
THIRTY MILLION AN HOUR EACH AND
VITA. ONLY ONE IN ONE HUNDRED
CALIFORNIANS WHO RECEIVED THE
CAL THE ITC IN TAX YOUR TWENTY
TWENTY USED A FREE SERVICE TO
FILE THEIR TAXES. THAT MEANS
NINETY NINE OUT OF THOSE ONE
HUNDRED YOU'D USED A PAID-SERVICE WHEN THEY WERE ELIGIBLE
FOR FREE SERVICES SUCH AS VITA.
MY FREE TAXES .ORG CALIFORNIA
LIKE CETERA. THE MAJORITY OF
THESE LOW INCOME CALIFORNIANS
WENT TO A PAID PREPARER COSTING
THEM SEVERAL HUNDRED DOLLARS
EACH. IF ONLY 1% OF THE OVER
THREE MILLION CALLIE ATC
ELIGIBLE TAX FILERS USED A FREE
FILE OPTION. WE NEED TO FACE THE
REALITY THAT COLLECTIVELY THE
MAJORITY. ARE PAYING MILLIONS OF
DOLLARS THEY SHOULDN'T HAVE TO
AND POTENTIALLY MISSING OUT ON
THE BENEFITS OF THE TAX CREDITS
THEMSELVES. SO WE HAVE TO ASK
WHERE IS THE DISCONNECT WE HAVE
ROBUST AND GROWING TAX CREDITS
AND FREE OPTIONS FROM IRS
CERTIFIED COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS. THE DISCONNECT IS
AND HOW MUCH WE SUPPORT CBO'S
THE GET THE WORD OUT AND PROVIDE
FREE TAX PREP. COMMUNITY
ENGAGEMENT IS NOT LIGHT WORK IT
IS DEEPLY ROOTED IN TRUST
RELATIONSHIPS AND CONTINUING TO
SHOW UP. IN THE STATE OF NEARLY
FORTY MILLION PEOPLE THERE WERE
ONLY TWO HUNDRED SIXTY SEVEN CBO
SAID OPERATED THREE HUNDRED
TWENTY FIVE OUR REGION VITA
SITES IN TWENTY TWENTY ONE. WE
CANNOT EXPECT THIS LIMITED
NUMBER OF CBO'S WHICH ARE
CURRENTLY FUNDED TO FUNCTION
ONLY SEVEN MONTHS OUT OF THE
YEAR WITH VOLUNTEERS TO SERVE
MILLIONS OF LOW INCOME
CALIFORNIANS SUCCESSFULLY. BUT
WE CANSET GOALS FOR GROWTH IF
THERE IS FUNDING IN GOALS FOR
GROWTH WILL BE NEEDED AS A VITAL
SERVICES REACH FULL CAPACITY
EVERY YEAR. ENTER CORREOS
DISTRICT THROUGH TEN DIFFERENT
VITA SITES 500-080-0409 TOTAL
RETURNS WERE FILED FOR FREE IN
TWENTY TWO THOUSAND TWENTY ONE.
BRINGING OVER NINE POINT SIX
MILLION DOLLARS IN TAX CREDITS
TO LOW INCOME FAMILIES. AND
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WICKS DISTRICT
BY TO SITES COMPLETED ROUGHLY
TWELVE HUNDRED RETURNS TOTALING
TWO POINT TWO MILLION IN TAX
CREDITS. TOTAL SAVINGS AND TAX
PREP FEES WERE NEARLY. THREE
HUNDRED TWENTY SEVEN THOUSAND
DOLLARS IN A SINGLE ASSEMBLY
DISTRICT. VITAL WORKS BUT WE
MUST GROW TO MEET DEMAND. AND
OUR REGION WIDE SPREAD
AVAILABILITY IS WHAT COMMERCIAL
PREPARERS USED TO CORNER THE
MARKET ON PAID TAX PREP. INTO IT
SPENT TWO POINT SIX BILLION IN
TWENTY TWENTY. TWENTY TWENTY ONE
ALONE ON SELLING AND MARKETING.
THIS IS JUST ONE COMPANY WITH A
FIFTH OF THE TOTAL. PAID TAX
PREP MARKET. ADVOCATES AND
COMMUNITY MEMBERS ARE NOT
SUGGESTING THAT THE STATE SPEND
THAT KIND OF MONEY IT DOESN'T
PRESENT THEMSELVES L. IT
JUSTIFICATION FOR STEPPING UP
OUR PRECEDENTS. FROM THIS YEAR'S
THIS CURRENT BUDGET YEAR OF
FIFTEEN MILLION OVER SEVEN
MONTHS TO. AGAIN FOR A FULL
TWELVE IN A- WAY. WE WOULD
EXPECT THAT WITH YOUR OVER YOUR
BASELINE INVESTMENTS WE COULD
GREATLY EXPAND OUR SERVICES AND
CULTURALLY AND LINGUISTICALLY
COMPETENT WAYS. AND SET ROBUST
TARGETS AND BENCHMARKS FOR
INCREASED FREE FILING. AS A NEW
OR EXPANDED TAX CREDITS ARE
ESTABLISHED LIKE THE FOSTER
YOUTH TAX CREDIT FOR THE
CALIFORNIA CHILD TAX CREDIT
PAYMENT WE WOULD HAVE A NETWORK
OF PARTNERS TO RELY ON TO TARGET
MESSAGING AND SERVICES. I WILL
END BY SHARING THE WORDS OF SOME
RAM NIAGARA WHO FILED HIS TAXES
VIA VITA PROVIDED BY UNITED
WAY'S FRESNO MADERA COUNTY'S. HE
SHARED. RIGHT IT IS A FANTASTIC
RESOURCE FOR PEOPLE OF ALL
BACKGROUNDS FOR SOMETHING AS
DIFFICULT AS TAXES IT SHOULD BE
A SERVICE OFFERED TO EVERYONE
AND DESERVED MORE FUNDING. THE
PEOPLE INVITED MAKE THE PROCESS
LOOKS SIMPLE WHICH IS HOW IT
SHOULD BE FOR EVERYONE TAXES ARE
HARD INVITED MAKES IT EASY.
PEOPLE SHOULD USE VITA SO
THEY'RE NOT WASTING THEIR TIME
AND MONEY FOR SOMETHING THAT
SHOULD BE SIMPLIFIED. INVITA
HELPS WITH THAT. SO WE ASK YOU
TO FUND OUR REGION BITE AND
THANK YOU. VERY MUCH MUCH MUCH
APPRECIATE- THE ISSUE THAT IS
BEING BROUGHT UP NOW. I DO HAVE
A COUPLE OF QUESTIONS THAT I
WANT TO- GET SOME ANSWERS TO
SPECIFICALLY WITH THE DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE. HAS THE NEED FOR E.
I. T. C. Y. C. T. C. VITA
PROGRAMS DECREASED SINCE LAST
YEAR'S BUDGET. DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. YEAH THAT WOULD THAT TO
FOR MY COLLEAGUE- KRISTALLNACHT
ARE NOT FAMILIAR WITH THAT THE
NEED FOR THE FINANCING CREASED.
IN TERMS OF IN TERMS OF THE NEED
FOR THE PROGRAM- I THINK THAT
DEPENDS ON A NUMBER OF FACTORS-
TURN TO THE INCOME NEEDS OF THE
RECIPIENTS- IN TERMS OF HELP
REACH- I THINK THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION HAS ON THE
PROPOSED FIFTEEN MILLION DOLLARS
IN THE CURRENT YEAR AND
PROPOSING ANOTHER TEN MILLION
DOLLARS IN THE BUDGET YEAR TO
CONTINUE OUR OUTREACH EFFORTS
FOR THE I. T.'S. YOUNG TECH.
MAKE HELLO PERCEPTS OR AWARE OF
THE STAR TO APPLY FOR. A MENTOR
OF THIS. STATUS OF THE RECIPIENT
AND THE RECIPIENTS THE POOL
ELIGIBLE PERSONS WHO ARE- WHO
CAN TAKE ADVANTAGE OF THESE- OF
THESE PROGRAMS I WOULD I WOULD
DEFER TO MY COLLEAGUES IN OUR
FORECASTING UNIT. SO THIS IS
JEANETTE HERRON I CAN SOME
INFORMATION IN REGARDS TO NOT.
SHOW I THINK IT'S BEEN SEVERAL
YEARS NOW SINCE WE HAVE BEEN AND
USING CASH INTO THE VITA SITES.
ONE THING THAT WE SAW ON THE
FLOOR TODAY BECAUSE CAPITA
DESTROYED THAT'S ON STOP PUBLIC
IS NOT WILDLIFE AND ENOUGH TO
SELL. DID NOT APPEAR TO BE
GROWING THANK YOU HAD TO SEE
RETURNS WITH ANOTHER UNIVERSE
MORE GROWING AND SO THE OUTRAGE
DOLLARS WE'RE GETTING- TO WHERE
WE NEEDED THEM TO GO TO GET MORE
PEOPLE THAT ARE CLAIMING THE
KELLY AGENCY TO PROPS MIGRATE.
TO THE FREE FUNDING SERVICE OR
FOR THE FIRST TIME I HAVE A
CHANCE RETURN I'M BUT AGAIN WITH
CHILDREN WHICH TOOK MANY OF THAT
IN PERSON SITES OFFLINE. LEAVING
LITTLE SUPPORT OR ONLINE SUPPORT
WHICH NOT EVERYONE IS
COMFORTABLE WITH THE STATISTICS
HAVE NOT YET RECOVERED OR I
GUESS I SHOULD SAY THE ACTIVITY
ITSELF HAS NOT YET RECOVERED. IN
REGARDS TO- PUTTING VITA AT THE
FOREFRONT TO ON TRACK TO COVER
THE SCOTT. SO THAT BEING SAID WE
STILL DO YOU SEE THAT THERE IS A
LARGE TRANSITORY POPULATION
ASSOCIATED WITH THIS CREDIT-
HISTORICALLY CLOSE PRE COATED WE
SAW ABOUT 40% OF INDIVIDUALS
CLAIM THE CREDIT YEAR OVER YEAR
WHICH MEANT ABOUT 60% OF FILERS
YEAR OVER YEAR WERE NEW FINE
ARTS. ON SO WITH COPELAND WE SAW
THAT NUMBER ACTUALLY ANALYZE
OBJECT FIFTY FIFTY- RANGE OR 50%
OF THE INDIVIDUALS CLAIMED AT
THE AIRPORT AND FIFTY PERCENT-
WERE NEEDED I AM EXPERT TIME
DURING THE COULD YEARS SO
UNCLEAR WHERE THAT TRIMBLE SUCH
BUT- THAT DOES SUGGEST. AGAIN I
NEED THAT THERE IS SOME
EDUCATION THAT IS APPROPRIATE
AND NECESSARY TO DO YEAR OVER
YEAR TO MAKE SURE THAT OUR FOLKS
THAT ARE ELIGIBLE. FOR THIS
CREDIT ARM BOX HEARING ABOUT IT.
I WILL SAY THAT THE WHITE IF OF
THESE AND YOU ELECTRONIC FILING
METHOD OPEN. SIX PER DO YOU. NOT
GET ME THAT THEY'RE EITHER USING
PREPARE AS BEST ALSO WHAT IS
MENTIONED OR THAT THEY ARE-
DOING THAT DOES. USING ON MY
STUFF TOOLS. SO HAVE THEM FROM
THAT SHOULD RAPID FIVE PER OF.
TYPICALLY FILED WITH THE PREPARE
. WHICH IS DEFINITELY IN STOCK
THAT IS VERY VERY HIGH- BUT NOT
INCONSISTENT WITH GENERAL
POPULATION. BUT PERHAPS BEING
ABLE TO AFFORD IT MORE SO AT THE
GENERAL POPULATION UP LEVEL TWO
FOR THOSE FEES VERSUS THE
INDIVIDUALS. THAT ARE CLAIMING
THESE ARE VERY IMPORTANT CREDIT
ON THE COUNT YET YOU SEE AN
YOUNG CHILD TAX CREDIT. SHOW THE
ONE THING THAT WE HAVE HEARD FOR
DECADES IN REGARDS TO WHAT MAKES
FIGHT AND NOT BEING SUCCESSFUL.
IS LOCATION. AND I KNOW THAT THE
OTHER KIDS IN THE COMMUNITY
BASED ORGANIZATIONS HAVE BEEN
WORKING VERY VERY HARD WITH
THESE GRANT FUNDING TO SET UP
NEW LOCATIONS AND OR TO EXPAND
HOURS WHICH HAS PROVED
EFFECTIVE- BUT THAT DOES NOT
MEAN THAT THE VOLUNTEERS ARE
FOLLOWING. WHICH MEANS THAT
SERVICES COULD IMPACT
COMPROMISED SO MANY ARMS
REQUESTED ADVOCATES IN THE
SENATE BILL FOURTEEN ONLINE
REPORT THAT I MENTIONED EARLIER
SECTIONS G. AND H. PROVIDE
INSIGHT INTO BENEFITS AND RESCUE
IT'S YOUR ROUND FUNDING OR
INCREASED FUNDING. ON SHOULD BE
PROVIDED THAT MIGHT ASSIST IN
ASSISTING THOSE THAT COMMUNITY
BASED ORGANIZATIONS AND OR THE
EXPANSION OF. FREE TAX FILING.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MS HERMAN
AND A NEED A LITTLE BIT OF CLEAR
FOR TO YOU STATED SO BEFORE COVE
IT DID I HEAR YOU CORRECTLY YOU
MENTIONED THAT YOU SAW AN
pFOR- EITC. SO MY COMMENTS- THANK
YOU FOR THE QUESTION SO MY
COMMENTS WERE IN REGARDS TO
RELIEVE THE NUMBER OF
INDIVIDUALS THAT CLAIM THE
CURRENT YEAR OVER YEAR. OFTEN
TIMES WHEN A TAX CREDIT IS
IMPLEMENTED IT IS PRESUMED THAT
IT'S GOING TO BE RELEVANT YEAR
OVER YEAR. AND SO ONCE YOU KNOW
ABOUT IT YOU DON'T HAVE TO KNOW
ABOUT IT AGAIN BECAUSE YOU JUST
AUTOMATICALLY GOING TO CRIMINAL
YEAR'S RETURN YOU HAVE A
CARRYOVER. CAL YET YOU SEE IS
UNIQUE IN THAT WAY AND THAT IT
REALLY IS FOCUSED AGAIN ON
LOWER. THANKS THEN THE INCOME
CHANNELS CHARM OR EXTREMELY IS
CAN BE VERY TRANSITORY UP AND
DOWN THE SCALE OF INCOME THAT
MAKES AN ELIGIBLE ONE YEAR AND
NOT ELIGIBLE THE NEXT. AND SO
THAT IS THE REFERENCE POINT THAT
I MADE EARLIER BEFORE KELVIN-
EVEN IN SPITE OF THE GROWTH
EVERY YEAR OF THE EXPANSION IS
PROBABLY THE BETTER WORD TO SAY
IN THE KALYANJI SIGNATURE. WE
SAW ABOUT FORTY PEOPLE 40% OF
THE FACTS CLAIMING THAT WERE
REPETITIVE CLAIMS YEAR OVER
YEAR. AND THEREFORE 60% WORK.
I'M SORRY THE- THOSE OF THE
INDIVIDUALS WE WILL WANT TO SURE
KNOW ABOUT IT AND SOME SHAPE
FORM SO THAT THEY DON'T ON THEIR
NOT AWARE THEY DON'T ACTION
OTHERWISE. SO WE OPEN WHAT WE
SAW AND MY LIKELY A RESULT OF
THE- CONTINUING CHALLENGING
ECONOMIC TIMES AND WE SAW MORE
PEOPLE CLAIM THAT YOU'RE OVER
HERE THAT- 40% HISTORICALLY WHEN
UP TO ABOUT 50% A LITTLE BIT
ABOUT 50% SO THAT FOR THE FIRST
TIME MORE PEOPLE ARE FINDING IT
YEAR OVER YEAR. UNLESS PEOPLE
WERE NEW TO THE PROGRAM HOWEVER
THERE STILL IS A MASSIVE AMOUNT
OF JOBS THAT ARE NEEDED EACH
YEAR- THAT HAVEN'T CLEANED IN
THE PAST AND THOSE ARE THE ONES
BELIEVE THAT THE OUTRAGE PER SE. IS MOST EFFECTIVE IN REGARDS
TO. THANK YOU FOR THAT- FOR THAT
. AND IF YOU IF YOU CAN
ELABORATE OR IF THE DEPARTMENT
OF- FINANCE CAN ELABORATE THE
BUDGET PROPOSES TEN MILLION FOR
OUT REACH WHAT WAS THE OUT REACH
DOLLARS FOR PREVIOUS YEARS. THE
CURRENT YEAR BUDGET- FOR OUT
REACHES A LEVEL OF ARTS FIFTEEN
MILLION DOLLARS- AGAIN WE ARE
PROPOSING TEN MILLION DOLLARS IN
THE BUDGET YEAR. THAT'S NOT A
REFLECTION ON THE SEA OF
OUTREACH- PER SE IT'S- JUST ON
THE AMOUNT OF FUNDING THAT WAS
AVAILABLE FOR OUR REGION THE
TOTALITY OF THE ADMINISTRATION
SPENDING PROPOSAL. SO I GUESS I
NEED A LITTLE BIT OF CLARITY
BECAUSE OF. NUMBERS THAT WE SAW
THAT REFLECTS A REDUCTION TO TEN
MILLION TO FIFTEEN MILLION IS
THAT ACCURATE. YES THAT IS
CORRECT- WE ARE CLOSING TEN
MILLION DOLLARS FOR THE BUDGET
YEAR AND AGAIN THAT'S NOT A
REFLECTION. ON THE ADMINISTRATOR
CAN VIEWS ON OUTREACH- IT'S JUST
THE AMOUNT OF. MONEY THAT WAS
AVAILABLE FOR OUTRAGE SPENDING
WITH THE AND THE FRAMEWORK THE-
ADMINISTRATION'S OVERALL
SPENDING PLAN FOR THE TWO
THOUSAND TWENTY TWO TWENTY THREE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET. WELL IF THE
BUDGET IS A REFLECTION OF OUR
VALUES AND WE HAD ALREADY
ALLOCATED FIFTEEN MILLION AND
YOU'RE COMING BACK WITH TEN
MILLION A REDUCTION OF FIVE
MILLION. THAT TELLS ME THAT ARE
REACHING TO LOW INCOME
COMMUNITIES THAT NEED THE
SUPPORT. ISN'T A PRIORITY. SO
GIVEN THE FACT THAT WE ARE
ENCODED RECOVERY AND INCOME
INEQUALITY IS A PRIORITY TO THE
LEGISLATURE. WIDE WHY MAKE A
WRITTEN A REDUCTION. OR A
REDUCTION IN TO SAY A FIVE
MILLION TO HELP LOW INCOME
FAMILIES ACROSS THE STATE. DID
MANAGE. AND YOU YOU HAVE BY IF
YOU CUT OFF AT THE BEGINNING OF
YOUR RESPOND AGAIN OVER.
CERTAINLY EACH CARRIED ON IT
BUDGETS HAS PROVIDED FUNDING FOR
EACH AND AGAIN THAT CHRISTIANS
PROPOSED A CONDITIONAL AND ROUTE
REACHING THE BUDGET YOU'RE AND
AGAIN THE AMOUNT THAT'S BEING
PROPOSED IS NOT A REFLECTION THE
FIVE MILLION DOLLAR REDUCTION A
REFLECTION OF THE
ADMINISTRATION'S VIEWS ON THE
EFFECTIVENESS OF OUTREACH IT IS
JUST ON THE AMOUNT AGAIN THAT
WAS AVAILABLE WITHIN THE
FRAMEWORK OF THE OVERALL
SPENDING PLAN. WELL SHE I'M
TRYING TO TALK WHAT IF I COULD
JUST INSERT CLARIFICATION POINT
FIVE MILLION ABOUT FIFTEEN
MILLION LAST YEAR WAS FOR RICH
RELATED TO GOLDEN STATE STIMULUS
PROGRAMS. ON AND FINANCES THAT
ALMOST COMPENSATION. APOLOGIES
WERE HAVING SOME SOME TECHNICAL
DIFFICULTIES SO I COULDN'T
REALLY QUITE HEAR THE RESPONSE
FROM MISTER WHITE OR THE
CONNECTION WITH YOUR COMMENT
NECESSARY MEANT. CAN YOU CAN YOU
CLARIFY THAT ONCE AGAIN. I'D BE
HAPPY TO TRY AGAIN HOPE WILL
COME THROUGH MORE CLEARLY THIS
TIME AGAIN THE- FIRST IS-
JEANNIE POINTED OUT. THE CURRENT
YEAR BUDGET HAS FIFTEEN MILLION
DOLLARS FOR OUTREACH OF WHICH
FIVE MILLION DOLLARS IS FOR.
WELL ROUNDED IS NO LONGER GOING
TO BE OFFERED OF IN THE BUDGET
YEAR SO WE'RE PROPOSING TEN
MILLION DOLLARS IN FUNDING- IN
THE BUDGET YEAR. FOR ON GOING
OUTREACH ACTIVITIES WHICH IS THE
SAME AS WAS PROPOSED FOR ONGOING
OUTREACH ACTIVITIES IN THE
CURRENT YEAR. THANK YOU FOR THAT
CLARIFICATION I APPRECIATED WE
JUST WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT AT
THE END OF THE DAY. AMID
ECONOMIC COVERT ECONOMIC
RECOVERY PLEASE WE ARE DOING
EVERYTHING WE POSSIBLY CAN TO
ENSURE THAT WE'RE HELPING. LOW
INCOME FAMILIES- THAT OBVIOUSLY
NEED THE SUPPORT- AS WE EXPAND-
EFFORTS FOR CALLIE I T. C. AS
WELL AS FOSTER YOUTH WITH JUST
CREDIBLE IMPORTANT. AND HONEST
FOR THE RIGHT. I AM A- OF THE
CONCEPT OF EXPANDING CAL ATC IN
FOSTER YOUTH THAT THANK YOU FOR
THE- THE DATA RELATED
SPECIFICALLY TO MY DISTRICT AND
THEY'RE SO MANY DISTRICTS ACROSS
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA IN
WHICH- I KNOW THAT THIS IS
INCREDIBLY. SPECIAL AND HELPFUL
TO WORKING FAMILIES. WHEN WE SEE
THAT THE BUDGET TRAILER
LANGUAGE- ON THIS PROPOSAL
ANOTHER ISSUE THAT KEEPS RISING
TO THE TOP OF THE LIST IS HOW WE
PROVIDE SUPPORT TO TAXPAYERS
WITH ZERO INCOME- THE MOST IN
NEED. OF ADDITIONAL HELP AND
THROUGH Y. C. T. C. PROPOSAL CAN
DEAL IF EXPLAINS. THE PROCESS
FOR HOW TAXPAYER WITH ZERO
INCOME WILL FILE A WRITTEN AND
TO RECEIVE Y. C. T. C. QUESTION
CALL THE WHITE PART OF FINANCE
AGAIN- THAT THE PROCESS FOR
CLAIMING THE RETIREMENT ZERO
INCOME WOULD BE NO DIFFERENT
THAN SOMEONE THAT HAD. HAPPENED
BECAUSE THEY WOULD NEED TO FILE
A CALIFORNIA RETURN AND CLAIM
THAT. CLAIM THAT YOUNG CHILD TAX
CREDIT ON ON CALPERS TO STATE
CALIFORNIA RETURN.
IT'S NOT CAN YOU JUST ELABORATE
ON THE DETAILS ON HOW THAT WOULD
WORK PLACE. WELL YOU WOULD YOU I
DON'T KNOW THAT THERE ARE-
ADDITIONAL DETAILS AS FAR AS IF
IT'S REALLY COMES DOWN TO THE
TAXPAYER BEING AWARE OF THE
CREDIT AND FILING FILING A STATE
TAX RETURN CLAIMING THE CREDIT.
ON THE ON THAT TAX RETURN. BUT
WHAT AN INDIVIDUAL TO FILE A
FEDERAL TAX RETURN TO BE ABLE
TO. FILE THE SAME STATE TAX
RETURN AND BE ELIGIBLE FOR
BENEFITS. I DON'T THINK THEY
WOULD NECESSARILY HAVE TO FILE A
FEDERAL RETURN IN ORDER TO DO
THAT- THIS IS A STATE A STATE
TAX CREDIT BUT GENERALLY YOU
WOULD EXPECT. THE TAXPAYER TO
FILE FEDERAL KERN AS IT FEEDS
THROUGH ON THE ON. THE DATE OF
THE START OF THE STATE TAX
RETURN. THANK YOU I THINK. LIKE
SOME CLARITY ON THAT MS HERMAN.
SIR THIS IS JEANNIE HERMAN
FRANCHISE DOT ORG- PERHAPS I CAN
OUT SOME CLARITY INTO ASSISTANCE
WELL CHAU CALIFORNIA LOT DOES
START WITH FEDERAL AGI- AND
THERE ARE TRANSACTION IN
EXISTENCE FOR DECADES AND THE ON
Q. REASONS WHY THAT IS BUT THAT
BECOMES VERY FRIENDLY IN THESE
TYPES OF SITUATIONS WHERE.
PERHAPS THERE IS NOT FINALLY
MORE FOR THE FACT OR STATE. BUT
THERE IS A INCENTIVE THAT
CLAIMED THE ATTACK BETWEEN THE
NEEDS TO BE. TAKEN CARE SO. HE
DOES NOT REACH CAN. OF AND
THERE'S RETURNS AND ON THE AGAIN
AS I MENTIONED IN MY TESTIMONY
WE ARE GOING TO BE. DOING OUR
BEST TO TRY TO IDENTIFY THESE
FOLKS THAT REALLY AREN'T VISIBLE
TO FRANCHISE TOP FOUR BUT NOT SO
IN THIS WILL PERHAPS TO SOME OF
OUR- PARTNER ORGANIZATIONS AND-
YES SENATE. HEALTH CARE
SERVICES. SO THAT THERE CAN BE
OUTREACH BUT WE'RE ALSO GOING TO
BE RELYING HEAVILY ON A
COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATIONS.
TO START PUTTING OUT FEELERS TO
SUGGESTS THAT- HANDED CREDIT.
FOR INDIVIDUALS SAID THAT- THEY
PERHAPS CAN GET SOME ATTENTION
OF FOLKS AS WELL THAT MIGHT NOT
OTHERWISE BE OUTREACH TEAM. ONE
THING INDIVIDUAL IDENTIFIES
THEMSELVES OR OUT REACHES
PERFORMED DIRECTLY RATHER LIKE
IT'S- SO THERE'S A COUPLE
DIFFERENT WAYS RATE TYPICALLY.
ALL RETURNS FROM ACROSS THE
NATION ARE PREDICATED ON THE
PLANNING OF THE TAX RETURN IN AN
ACCURATE TAX RETURN. WHICH
GENERALLY INCLUDES THE
COMBINATION OF FINE IN. FEDERAL
AND STATE TAX RETURNS. AND THIS
IS- AGAIN FOR MANY READ BECAUSE
WE'RE NOT ONLY JUST TRYING TO
PROTECT THE STATE BUT WE'RE
ACTUALLY TRYING TO TAP THE
TAXPAYER. AND WHEN RETURNED
EFFORTS FOR FILING FALL OUTSIDE
OF THAT TYPICAL REGIME THAT CAN
BE A HAPPY- ADVENTURE FOR FRAUD.
TO TAKE OVER WHICH MEANS THAT WE
HAVE TO HELP TAXPAYERS ONLINE A
LOT OF THINGS THAT WE DON'T WANT
TO HAVE TO HELP THEM ONLINE BUT
IT CAN IT BE STOPPED AND OTHER
THINGS. UNCERTAINLY ALLOWS- OR
PUTS US THE STATE AT A
DISADVANTAGE THAT WE HAVE TO
SPEND RESOURCES ON COMBATING
FRAUD. AND GETTING MONEY INTO
THE HANDS OF THE STROKES. SELL
OPTIONS THAT THEY CAN DO PUSHING
WATER WILL BE CRITICAL AND THE
SITUATION. SO THAT THE
INDIVIDUALS CAN GET ASSISTANCE
TO FILE AND OUR STATE OF THE
MINIMUM LOOKING TO GET MAKE SURE
THERE IS NO VALUE TO FILING THE
STATE RETURN. BECAUSE THERE MAY
NOT BE VALUE TO DATE DOESN'T
MEAN THERE'S NOT A VALUE LATER
WITH THE NET TAX INCENTIVES THAT
MIGHT BE ADOPTED IN THE FUTURE.
THAT THEY COULD ACTUALLY CLAIM.
BY DOING A LOT OF THESE FOLKS-
WE WOULD WANT TO MAKE SURE THE
PACKAGE IS THAT. IN THE EVENT
THAT A RETURN AT THE FEDERAL
LEVEL HAS NO VALUE. FIND IT
WOULD CERTAINLY BE ABLE TO FILE
ONLY THE STATE TAX RETURN. YOUR
LAST AND. AGAIN IT'S A FREE TAX
PREPARATION SERVICE. IN THE
EVENT THAT. AN INDIVIDUAL-
CHOOSES NOT TO GET IF I ORGAN
NOT AWARE VYTORIN ISN'T. SITE
OPEN. THEY CAN. HOW FILE TO DO
THE- I'M AND THAT'S WHERE GETS
TRICKY BECAUSE I WOULD. BE ONE
OF THE THAT THE INDIVIDUAL JUST
PLUG IN ZERO. ON THEIR FILING.
ON THAT'S GOING TO HAPPEN
QUICKLY NOT AND YOU FRONT
ROUTINES- INAPPROPRIATELY SO AND
IT'S GOING TO TRIGGER A LOT OF
OUTREACH SO. WE ARE STILL
NOODLING THROUGH WHAT THIS WOULD
LOOK LIKE AS FAR AS OPTIONS TO
GET THEM INTO THE DOOR
SIMPLISTICALLY. AND LEAST COSTLY
AS POSSIBLE. BUT I DON'T FEEL
LIKE WE HAVE ALL THE ANSWERS. TO
QUESTIONS TODAY. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIRMAN I A- THE A-
CONTACT TO THE SITUATION AT
HAND. I HEARD YOU SAY AND THIS
IS THE PART THAT SO I'M A LITTLE
JUST PERPLEXED ABOUT. I HEARD
YOU SAY THE RELIANCE AND NEED TO
ENSURE THAT WE'RE WORKING WITH-
A- COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATIONS
OR CBO'S ON THE GROUND. AT TO DO
THIS SPECIFIC OUTREACH PLAN AND
ENSURING THAT MORE FAMILIES HAVE
ACCESS TO THESE RESOURCES BUT
YET AT THE SAME TIME WHILE
REDUCING THE FUNDING FOR
OUTREACH PLANS. I'M NOT QUITE
SURE HOW THAT- ALIGNS AND SO I'M
I'M GOING TO. THINK TALK A
LITTLE BIT MORE AS WE MOVE THIS
ALONG BECAUSE I DO THINK. FROM
MY EXPERIENCE ON SITTING IN THE
IN THIS COMMITTEE IS THAT
THERE'S A LOT OF RELIANCE ON
CBO'S ON A LOT OF DIFFERENT
PERSPECTIVES. AND AS WE KNOW.
OVERWORKED UNDERSTAFFED UNDER
RESOURCE. THOSE ARE THE
EXPERIENCES OF THE CBO'S IN MY
COMMUNITY AND ACROSS THE STATE
WHEN I TALK TO OTHER. OTHER
MEMBERS SO. I WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE ARE. APPROPRIATING
FUNDING NECESSARY TO ENSURE THAT
WE ARE ACTUALLY PROVIDING THE
RESOURCES ON THE GROUND THAT ARE
NEEDED. TO ENSURE THE MORE
FAMILIES HAVE ACCESS TO
RESOURCES AND THAT INCLUDES. OUR
REACH DOLLARS I'M JUST CURIOUS
AS TO WHY INSTEAD OF. I
REDUCING- THAT OPPORTUNITY FOR
TO BE ABLE TO HELP WORKING
FAMILIES ACROSS THE STATE. SO
AGAIN THANK YOU FOR THE TIME AND
THE ANSWERS AND WE'RE GONNA.
WE'RE GONNA KEEP THIS ITEM OPEN
FOR THE MOMENT AND WE'RE GOING
TO MOVE ON TO ISSUE NUMBER SIX
THANK YOU TO THE PANELISTS THAT
WERE HERE THANK YOU FOR THE IN
PERSON TESTIMONY THINK IS THE
FIRST TIME. I THINK WE'VE HAD IT
. SUBSTANCE OF THE STATUS OF
WOMEN AND GIRLS WAS OUR FIRST
ONE BUT THANK YOU MUCH
APPRECIATED. WE'RE GOING TO MOVE
ON TO ISSUE NUMBER SIX WHICH
INCLUDES- WORKLOAD EXPANSION-
MISS HERRIMAN. THANK YOU AGAIN
GEN JERRY HERMAN TRAIN TRAIN
TRACKS BOARD THIS PROPOSAL
REQUEST F. T. V.'S- RESOURCES TO
ACCOMMODATE WORK ON FOR F. T. B.
TO COMPLETE SECTION FORTY ONE
REPORTS AND OR DATA I'M
GATHERING AND SHARING WITH
RELEVANT INDIVIDUALS THAT MIGHT
OTHERWISE DO THOSE REPORTS
FRANCHISE TAX BOARD IS
REQUESTING FOR PERMANENT
POSITIONS IN TWENTY TWO TWENTY
THREE IN ADDITIONAL ONE POSITION
TWENTY FOUR TWENTY FIVE WITH
RELATED FUNDING. THIS WILL ALLOW
IT TO BE TOO MANY. OR YOU TO THE
VOLUME BILLS THAT ARE CHEN THE
SECTION ONE REPORTING. FORTY ONE
AS YOU KNOW WAS ORIGINALLY
ENACTED IN TWENTY SIXTEEN AND
THEN TWENTY NINETEEN SUN
EXPANSION TO INCLUDE NOT JUST
TAX CREDITS BUT ALSO TAX
EXPENDITURES THAT MIGHT CONTINUE
ON THE RETURN. YES WORK BUT DOES
REQUIRE A TO BE TO ENSURE
RELEVANT DATA IS ACCESSIBLE
INUNDATED AS A THAT USED BY UP
TO THE EDGE OF THE REQUIRED
ANNUAL REPORT. WHAT THE
INFORMATION CAN BE PROVIDED TO
ANOTHER DEPARTMENT WHO HAS BEEN
TASKEDWITH WRITING IN THE
ANNUAL REPORT. WHAT'S YOUR NAME
GENDER LAST THE QUESTION OF HOW
THESE REPORTS ARE TYPICALLY DONE
AND THE REVIEW PROCESS SAID
THANK YOU FOR THAT QUESTION.
BASICALLY WHAT I WOULD SAY IS
TYPICALLY WE NEED DURING THE
MONTH OF JANUARY IS JANUARY
AFTER FILING FEES AND SO THIS
PAST JANUARY FOR THE TWENTY.
TWENTY TAX RETURN. WE WILL FOR
THE FIRST TIME ABLE TO RELATE
AGGREGATE DATA FROM ALL TWENTY
TWENTY TAX RETURNS THAT WERE
FILED. AND SO ON AND THAT IS THE
END OF JANUARY SO WE VERY
QUICKLY PULL THE DATA THAT HAS
BEEN ESTABLISHED TO CAPTURE.
WHETHER IT IS A TAX CREDIT OR
TAX EXPENDITURE REPORT WE
ANALYZED IT WE BEGAN DRAFTING
THE REPORT- INTERNALLY THERE'S
THREE LEVELS OF REVIEW. THAT
RETAIL AND THEN WE HAVE A LEVEL
LEVEL. ALSO ENTERED INTO SEE.
AND THEN ON CERTAIN REPORTS BUT
MANY REPORTS WE HAVE A REVIEW
ARM AND THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE.
ACTION REQUEST PROCESS THE CORE
PROCESS. AND SO- SO MANY OF OUR
AND THROUGH MULTI LEVELS ARE
REVIEW BUT THAT SHE HAD. YOU AT
ALL ASK THE QUESTION IS HOW DO
ISSUE THE REPORT THE EXTRA
GENERATED. TO THE CAKE. THAT ARE
GIVEN TO US ON WHICH ARE
TYPICALLY GOING TO BE A SENATE
ASSEMBLY- Q. STOCK NUMBER
TYPICALLY ASSOCIATED WITH JAIL
THE STATE. AND THEN THOSE
REPORTS ARE TRANSMITTED- ACROSS
THE VARIOUS SENATE AND ASSEMBLY
OFFICES. THAT MAKE FIND OR TO
BE. THAT REPORT IS ALSO ONLINE
AS SOON AS WE'RE ABLE TO GET IT
UP AND RUNNING ON OUR OPEN DATA
PORTAL. THAT ALLOWS FOLKS TO ON
THE PUBLIC TO ACCESS AND
UNDERSTAND THOSE REPORTS. SO AT
THIS POINT THANK YOU FOR YOUR
QUESTIONS AND ALLOWING ME TO
ENTER DISTRICT TOPIC AND I'M
HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS
YOU MAY HAVE. THANK YOU WERE
GOING TO GO TO THE L. A. O.
PLACE- BROWN WHETHER FOR THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE SO
THE PROPOSAL REFLECTS A LARGE
INCREASE IN THE NUMBER OF NEW
TAX CREDITS THAT HAVE BEEN
ADOPTED A LOT. OVER THE LAST TWO
YEARS. AND IT ASSUMES THAT THE
LEGISLATURE WILL CONTINUE TO
ADOPT AROUND FOR NEW TAX CREDITS
ANNUALLY. SO WE FIND THAT THE
PROPOSAL FOR ADDITIONAL STAFF IN
TWENTY TWENTY TWO AND TWENTY.
TWENTY THREE IS REASONABLE BASED
ON. THE ON THE INCREASED
WORKLOAD. THE REQUEST ALSO
INCLUDES ONE ADDITIONAL POSITION
BEGINNING IN TWENTY TWENTY FOUR
TWENTY FIVE. AND THAT'S BASED ON
THE ASSUMPTION THAT THE NUMBER
OF NEW TAX CREDITS CONTINUES TO
INCREASE AT THE RATE HAS A
ROBUST COUPLE OF YEARS. SO IF
YOU THINK THE LEGISLATURE WILL
ADOPT SIGNIFICANTLY FEWER TAX
CREDITS OVER THE COMING YEARS.
YOU COULD CONSIDER REJECTING
THAT PART OF THE REQUEST AND
PERHAPS COMING BACK TO IT LATER
ON. SINCE IT IS FOR TWENTY
TWENTY FOUR TWENTY FIVE. THANK
YOU DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
BRISTOL THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE- WE SUPPORT THIS
PROPOSAL GRANTING INTERNET
QUESTIONS THE NUMBERS MAY HELP.
THANK YOU SO MUCH ARE THERE ARE
NO. OTHER THAN MYSELF WE'RE
GONNA MOVE ON WE'RE GOING TO
HOLD THIS OPEN FOR THE MOMENT
AND WE'RE GONNA MOVE ON TO ISSUE
NUMBER SEVEN. THANK YOU TO THE
PANELISTS OF ISSUE NUMBER SIX.
ISSUE SEVEN TAX PAYMENT
FLEXIBILITY FOR LOW INCOME AND
MODERATE INCOME HOUSEHOLDS AND
INNOVATION HEADQUARTERS CREDIT-
MISTER WHITE TO DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR-
STARTING WITH THAT FIRST ISSUE
OF THE PANDEMIC'S NEGATIVE
ECONOMIC EFFECTS-
DISPROPORTIONATELY AFFECTED LOW
AND MODERATE INCOME HOUSEHOLDS
THEREFORE THIS PROPOSAL PROVIDES
FLEXIBILITY TO CALIFORNIA
TAXPAYERS WHO MAY BE STRUGGLING
FINANCIALLY BY ALLOWING THEM TO
LATER TAX PAYMENTS AND NOT INCUR
INTEREST OR PENALTIES RELATED
EIGHT FIVE. IT'S IT WOULD BE
OPERABLE FOR TAX YEARS TWENTY
NINETEEN TWENTY TWENTY AND
TWENTY TWENTY ONE. BECAUSE
PAYMENT DUE DATES RELATED THOSE
YEARS WERE AFTER THE ONSET OF
THE PANDEMIC. SPECIFICALLY
SINGLE TAXPAYERS EARNING LESS
THAN SEVENTY FIVE THOUSAND AND
MARRIED FILING JOINTLY HOUSEHOLD
JOINT HOUSEHOLDS EARNING LESS
THAN A HUNDRED FIFTY THOUSAND
WOULD HAVE UNTIL SEPTEMBER
THIRTIETH TWENTY TWENTY THREE TO
PAY THEIR TAXES FOR THOSE.
SPECIFIED TAX YEARS INTEREST AND
PENALTIES WOULD BEGIN TO ACCRUE
A NEW AS OF OCTOBER ONE TWENTY
TWENTY THREE- ON ANY ON. ANY
UNPAID BALANCE IN SITUATIONS
WHERE AN ELIGIBLE TAXPAYER HAS
ALREADY MADE A LATE PAYMENT FOR
THE ELIGIBLE TAXPAYERS AND PAY A
LATE PENALTY OR INTEREST THE
AFTER THE WILL AUTOMATICALLY
REFUND. THE PENALTIES AND
INTEREST. THE SECOND ISSUE IS
THE INNOVATION HEADQUARTERS
CREDIT ADD THIS NEW TAX CREDIT
WOULD BE IN PLACE FROM TAX YEARS
TWO THOUSAND TWENTY TO THIRTY
THOUSAND TWENTY FOUR. AND WOULD
PROVIDE A NEW RESEARCH CREDIT
FOR COMPANIES INVESTING IN
ACTIVITIES AND TECHNOLOGIES THAT
MITIGATE CLIMATE CHANGE AND THE
COMPANIES ARE HEADQUARTERED IN
CALIFORNIA. THE CREDIT WOULD BE
ADMINISTERED BY THE FRANCHISE
TAX BOARD WOULD TARGET A REVENUE
LOSS OF TWO HUNDRED FIFTY
MILLION PER YEAR- THIS PROPOSAL
IS IT RECOGNIZES THE IMPORTANT
ROLE OF RESEARCH AND INNOVATION
IN CONFRONTING THE STATE'S
CLIMATE CRISIS AND AS ONE OF A
SERIES OF SIGNIFICANT
INVESTMENTS- THE STATE
ADMINISTRATION MAKING TO SUPPORT
THE STATE'S CLIMATE GOALS. WITH
THAT I CONCLUDE MY REMARKS AND
HAPPY TO TAKE ANY QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU MISTER WHITE- MISTER
WEATHERFORD. HELLO YES SPRING
WEATHER FOR DELIO AND- WE DON'T
HAVE COMMENTS ON THESE PROPOSALS
AT THIS TIME OR WAITING FOR THE
TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE. THANK YOU
MUCH. IT WE'RE GOING TO HOLD
THIS ITEM OPEN UNTIL WE HAVE
ADDITIONAL LANGUAGE THAT WE CAN
REVIEW. THANK YOU TO AT A
PANELIST ON ISSUE NUMBER SEVEN
WE ARE GOING TO GO TO PUBLIC
COMMENT EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN SIX
NINE TWO EIGHT NINE FIVE SEVEN.
ONE THREE ONE FIVE ONE TWO SEVEN
IS A PUBLIC ASSET ACCESS CODE
OPERATOR YOU MAY BEGIN. WE HAVE
A TESTIMONY ONE MOMENT WE HAVE A
TESTIMONY RIGHT HERE IN THE
ROOM. PLEASE BEGIN YOU HAVE ONE
MINUTE. GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM
CHAIR AND MEMBERS PAHLAVI ASK OF
THE COUNTY WELFARE DIRECTORS
ASSOCIATION HERE AS A MEMBER OF
THE CAL EITC COALITION. WE ARE
IN SUPPORT OF THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSALS LISTED UNDER ISSUE
NUMBER FIVE TO EXPAND THE EITC
TO FOSTER YOUTH. AND TO EXPAND
THE YOUNG CHILD TAX CREDIT TO
FAMILIES THAT FILE RETURNS ABOUT
INCOME. WE LOOK FORWARD TO
ENGAGING WITH THE ADMINISTRATION
ON THE SPECIFIC DETAILS RELATED
TO THE I TWO C. EXPANSION. FOR
FOSTER YOUTH. THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS AND
WE LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH
HIM. THANK YOU OPERATOR PLEASE
BEGIN. THANK YOU. TO JOIN THE
QUEUE FOR PUBLIC COMMENT YOU MAY
PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO ON
YOUR TELEPHONE KEYPAD AGAIN
THAT'S ONE AND THEN ZERO. IF YOU
HAVE NOT ALREADY DONE SO. WE'LL
GO FIRST TO LINE FOURTEEN ONE
FOUR. JUST A POINT OF THE- YOU
HAVE ONE MINUTE. YES MA'AM
AFTERNOON THAT INSURANCE MEMBERS
OF THE COLD WAR TOMEN ON BEHALF
OF THE CHILDREN'S PARTNERSHIP IN
SUPPORT OF ISSUE FIVE THE
EXPANSION OF THE EITC TO FOSTER
YOUTH AND YOUNG CHILD TAX CREDIT
TO FAMILIES THAT FILE RETURNS
WITHOUT INCOME TAX CREDITS ARE
CRITICAL IN PROTECTING THE
HEALTH AND WELL BEING OF
CHILDREN- INCOME SIGNIFICANTLY
CONTRIBUTES TO OPPORTUNITIES FOR
GOOD HEALTH A RECENT STUDY FOUND
THAT CASH STIPENDS PROVIDED TO
MOTHERS FOR THE FIRST YEAR OF
THEIR CHILDREN'S LIVES APPEARS
TO HAVE CHANGED THE BABY'S BRAIN
ACTIVITIES. AND WAYS OFFICIATED
WITH STRONGER COGNITIVE
DEVELOPMENT FOSTER YOUTH
TRANSITIONING TO ADULTHOOD THREE
SERIOUS INSTABILITY IN THEIR
LIVES BRINGING STABILITY TO BE
SEATED AS THEY ADJUSTED THE
TRANSITION TO ADULTHOOD SPORTS
ARE ECONOMIC AND WELL BEING
PROJECTIONS LONG AFTER. THEY
RECEIVE THESE FUNDS. THANK YOU
FOR YOUR CONSIDER. OUR NEXT
COMMENT WILL COME FROM LINE
SEVENTEEN. THAT THAT IS YOUR
LINE LINE SEVENTEEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD- HELLO THE GOOD AFTERNOON
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS MY NAME
IS PATRICK GAPPING I AM A FORMER
FOSTER YOUTHFROM SACRAMENTO
COUNTY AND I AM CALLING IN
SUPPORT OF ITEM NUMBER FIVE. THE
FOSTER YOUTH TAX CREDIT AND THE
PROPOSAL FROM THE- AND THE
PROPOSALS FROM THE AMSTRAD
POVERTY COALITION AND THE- CAL
YEAH A- PC COLLECTION WE ARE IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL INCLUDING NEW
REFUNDABLE TAX CREDITS HER
FORMER COUNTRY. ADJUSTING THE
YOUNG CHILD TAX CREDIT TO KEEP
PACE WITH INFLATION IN THE
ELIMINATION IMPORTANT
REQUIREMENTS FOR CHILDREN. IN
HOUSEHOLDS TO BENEFIT FROM THE
YOUNG CHILD TAX CREDIT WE ALSO
URGE THE LEGISLATOR- BUT TO
INCREASE THE POWER E. I. T. C.
MINIMUM FOR ALL TAX FILERS AND
COUNTRY TAX PREP ASSISTANCE
GRANT. BUT IT'S FASTER YOU NEED
THE SUPPORT AS THEY LEARN THE
SKILLS OF TAX FILING OF YOUNG
ADULTS. THANK YOU SO MUCH.
CONNECT COMMENT AS LINE NINETEEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS KERRY ONLY
WITH ECONOMIC SECURITY PROJECT
ACTION I'M CALLING IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF THE PROPOSAL POSTED
UNDER ISSUE NUMBER FIVE THAT THE
CREATION OF THE FOSTER YOUTH TAX
CREDIT EXPANSION OF THE YOUNG
CHILD TAX CREDIT TO FAMILIES
THAT FILE- RETURNS WITHOUT
EARNING HIM INCREASING THE OUR
REGION FREE TAX PREP FUNDING
FROM THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSED TEN
MILLION TO. THIRTY MILLION
DOLLAR ONGOING FUNDING IN ORDER
TO CREATE YEAR ROUND FUNDING TO
CBO SAID WE GET MORE PEOPLE TO
TAX CREDIT THANK YOU MEMBER OF
THE CANADIAN MADAM CHAIR AND-
THANK YOU I'M. TRUMP TO
PORTUGUESE MUCH FOR YOUR SUPPORT
. I NEXT COMMENT COMES FROM LINE
TEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. THIS IS
MOLLY SHEEHAN WITH THE
CALIFORNIA CATHOLIC CONFERENCE
WE ARE IN SUPPORT OF ITEM NUMBER
FIVE WHICH PROVIDES BOTH THE
THANK YOUNG CHILD TAX CREDIT
EXPANSION THE FAMILIES WITHOUT
INCOME AND THE BOSS YOU TAX
CREDIT EXPANSION- JUST KNOWING
THAT THE ISSUE THAT PASSED YOU
STATUS THE INCENTIVIZE ASIAN FOR
THEM TO BE ABLE TO FILE FOR.
TAXES WOULD ALLOW THEM TO HAVE
GREATER INCOME AND GREATER-
POSSIBILITIES FOR THE FUTURE SO
FOR THESE REASONS PLEASE PUT
THAT THANK YOU SO MUCH MADAM
CHAIR AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
NEXT WE HAVE LINE TWENTY FOUR.
AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS TUNING THE SOLICITOUS I
AM A FORMER FOSTER YOUTH CALLING
FROM VENTURA COUNTY AND I'M
CALLING IN SUPPORT OF ITEM
NUMBER FIVE. THANK YOU SO MUCH.
NINE TWENTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR
AND MEMBERS MY NAME IS CODY VAN
VELDEN I AM A COURT OR A FORMER
FOSTER YOUTH FROM SACRAMENTO
COUNTY I'M CALLING IN SUPPORT OF
ITEM NUMBER FIVE THANK YOU. NEXT
WE HAVE LINE TWENTY NINE. NAQUIN
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS MONEY
FIFTEEN HUNDRED GREAT AND HOW
POVERTY IN CALIFORNIA ALL TO
SUPPORT THE COLLEGE YOU CAN CAN
COALITION AMONG STRONG SUPPORT
PART. UNDER ISSUE NUMBER FIVE
ESPECIALLY TO INCREASE OUT WHICH
INCREASED TAX PERFORMING FROM
THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSED TEN
MILLION TO THIRTY MILLION SHARED
MEETING EXISTING AND TAX CUTS
PRODUCTS AND COMMANDED BY THE
STATE OR THE STRATEGY MUST THANK
YOU SO MUCH. WINE TWENTY EIGHT.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR MEMBERS THE
COMMITTEE THIS IS ANNA JOHNSON
WITH JOHN BURTON ADVOCATES FOR
YEARS CALLING IN SUPPORT OF
ISSUE NUMBER FIVE THE PROPERTY
TAX CREDIT THE YOUNG CHILD TAX
CREDIT AND ARE THE EXPANSION TO-
THE TEN MILLION FOR- EDUCATION
IN OUR REACH GRANT. WE KNOW
FIRST HAND HOW IMPORTANT IT IS
TO FUND THESE PROGRAMS AND
ENSURE FOSTER YOU HAVE OPPOSED
TO THEIR INCOME THEY ARE-
THEY'VE LOST A LOT OF WORK IN
THE PANDEMIC THEY'VE LOST
EDUCATIONAL TIENEN RECESSION
THEN RECOVERY CAN TAKE A LOT TO
HEAL FROM- INCLUDING FINANCIALLY
AND WE REALLY. RESPECT THIS
PROPOSAL IN THE SUPPORT-
DISCUSSED TODAY AND ALSO WE KNOW
FIRST HAND HOW MUCH IT TAKES TO
LAUNCHING NEW VITA SITE AND
OUTREACH TO YOUNG PEOPLE MAKE
SURE THEY HAVE ALL OF THEIR
DOCUMENTS AND ARE READY TO FILE
CORRECTLY AND ALSO THAT THEY
HAVE ASSISTANCE OVERCOMING ANY
TAX FRAUD OR IDENTITY THEFT
THAT. THEY MAY HAVE EXPERIENCE
BECAUSE OF THEIR TIME IN THE
SYSTEM SO WE THANK YOU FOR YOUR
CONTINUED SUPPORT AND ASSISTANCE
AND EVERYTHING- THAT YOU
COMMENTED ON TUESDAY THANK YOU.
OUR NEXT COMMON IS LINE TWENTY
SEVEN. GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM
CHAIR MEMBERS MY NAME IS ALEXIS
I'M A FORMER FOSTER YOUTH FROM
SACRAMENTO COUNTY I'M CALLING IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF ITEM NUMBER
FIVE THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME FOR
THIS ISSUE IN CONSIDERATION.
NEXT WE HAVE LINE THIRTY ONE.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR AND MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE MY NAME IS
CHANNELING MARLIN NUMBER FORMER
FOSTER ORANGE COUNTY I'M CALLING
IN SUPPORT OF ITEM NUMBER FIVE
THE FOSTER TAX CREDIT AND THE
PROPOSALS FROM THE END CHILD
POVERTY COALITION AND THE CAL
EITC COALITION I ALSO URGE THE
LEGISLATURE TO INCREASE THE CAL
EITC MINIMUM ALL TAX FILERS AND
FUND THREE HAWK. ASSISTANT GRANT
BECAUSE POSTURES NEED THE
SUPPORT OF THE LEARN THE SKILLS
OF TAX FILING. BY THE YOUNG
ADULT THANK YOU SO MUCH. NEXT WE
HAVE LINE TWENTY TWO. GOOD
AFTERNOON EVERYONE MY NAME IS
DONNA GLOBAL EXCEL AGAIN
INVINCIBLE ALSO CALLING IN PART
OF THE KELLY AGENCY COALITION
I'M CALLING TO REPORT AN ISSUE
NUMBER FIVE WE STRONGLY SUPPORT
THE BUDGET REQUEST INCREASE TO
THIRTY MILLION DOLLARS TO THE
COURT EXPAND THE COLLIE A TWO
FEET OUTRAGE AND FREE TAX
PREPARATION ASSISTANCE GRANTS
FOR LOW INCOME CALIFORNIANS. AT
A TIME OF GREAT ECONOMIC AND
SECURITY THE NEED FOR INCREASED
OUTREACH EDUCATION THEY TALK
WITH THEM THAT'S CRITICAL. WE
THANK YOU FOR YOUR SUPPORT. NEXT
WE'LL GO TO LINE. THIRTEEN GOOD
AFTERNOON MY NAME IS JORDAN SOSA
CALLING ON BEHALF OF CALIFORNIA
YOUTH CONNECTION A STATEWIDE
MEMBERSHIP ORGANIZATION OF
CURRENT AND FORMER FALL SHE'S
AND CALLING IN SUPPORT OF ITEM
NUMBER FIVE THE FALL SHE'S TAX
CREDIT AND THE PROPOSALS FROM
THE END CHILD POVERTY COALITION
IN THE KALECKI ITC COALITION
WERE ALSO CALLING IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL TO INCLUDE A NEW
REFUNDABLE TAX CREDIT FOR FORMER
BOSS YOU. ADJUSTING THE YOUNG
CHILD TAX CREDIT TO KEEP PACE
WITH INFLATION AND THE
ELIMINATION OF WORKING
REQUIREMENTS FOR CHILDREN IN
ZERO INCOME HOUSEHOLDS TO
BENEFIT FROM THE YOUNG CHILD TAX
CREDIT WE ALSO CALL AND URGE THE
LEGISLATURE TO INCREASE THE
CALATHEA PC MINIMUM FOR ALL TAX
FILERS AND FIND FREE TAX PREP
ASSISTANCE GRANTS BECAUSE BOSS
SHE NEEDS THE SUPPORT SYSTEMS. I
THINK FORMER BOSS SHE FROM LOS
ANGELES COUNTY IN THE CURRENT
FOSTER PARENTS AT SACRAMENTO
COUNTY THESE TAX CREDITS HAVE
BEEN VERY BENEFICIAL TO KEEP OUR
FAMILY. OUT OF POVERTY THANK
YOU. OUR NEXT COMMENT AS THE
FROM LINE TWENTY ONE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. HI MY NAME IS AS ANY
GUN LAST SUMMER. FORMER BOXER
YOU FROM SACRAMENTO COUNTY AND I
AM CALLING IN SUPPORT OF OUR THE
NUMBER FIVE FOR THE FOSTER YOUTH
TAX CREDIT AND THE PROPOSALS TO
END CHILD. POVERTY COALITION AND
THE CHILD D. I. T. C. COALITION
AND I ALSO AM IN STRONG SUPPORT
OF THE OVERNOR'S PROPOSAL FOR
THE U. CHILD TAX CREDIT THANK
YOU. NEXT WE HAVE LINE THIRTY.
HELLO MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS MY
NAME IS JAKE HOW CAN YOU KNOW
CALLING FROM THE CALIFORNIA
LINES OF CHILD AND FAMILY
SERVICES AND I'M ALSO CALLING IN
SUPPORT OF THE FOSTER YOUTH TAX
CREDIT AND THE PROPOSAL FROM THE
END CHILD POVERTY COALITION AND
THE CAL THEI. P. C. COALITION.
WARREN STRONG SUPPORT OF THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL TO INCLUDE A
NEW REFUNDABLE TAX CREDIT
PERFORMANCE AFTER YOU ADJUSTING
THE YOUNG CHILD TAX CREDIT TO
KEEP PACE WITH INFLATION AND THE
ELIMINATION OF WORKING
REQUIREMENTS FOR CHILDREN AND
THEY'RE ALL INCOME HOUSEHOLDS TO
BENEFIT FROM THE YOUNG CHILD TAX
CREDIT WE'RE ALSO IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF. AND I GOT THE
COMMENTS FROM THE FORMER FOSTER
YOUTH THAT HAVE BEEN ON THE CALL
AS WELL AS JOHN BURTON ADVOCATES
FOR YOU THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS WE LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH THE
COMMITTEE. OUR NEXT COMMENT WAS
FROM NINE THIRTY TO. GOOD
AFTERNOON MARKET SHE DROVE
REPRESENTING THE LOS ANGELES
COUNTY BOARD OF SUPERVISORS OR
AT THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSED IF
YOU FIVE MILLION DOLLARS IN ON
COURT GENERAL FUND. THE YOUNG
CHILD TAX CREDIT I THOUGHT THE
NINETEEN MILLION DOLLARS TO
INSPECT THE YOUNG CHILD TAX
CREDIT TRANSLATION BEGINNING IN
TAX YEAR TWENTY TWENTY TWO. THE
PROPOSAL WILL CONTINUE TO
PROVIDE A MEANINGFUL ECONOMIC
BOOST TO FAMILIES WITH YOUNG
CHILDREN THANK YOU. NINE THIRTY
FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HELLO
THIS IS KEVIN GO WITH A FRIEND
COMMITTEE ON LEGISLATION IN
CALIFORNIA WE ARE IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF THE PROPOSAL'S LISTED
UNDER ISSUE NUMBER FIVE. THE
FOSTER YOUTH TAX CREDIT
EXPANSION EXPANDING THE YOUNG
CHILD TAX CREDIT TO FAMILIES
WITH THE FILE RETURNS WITHOUT
INCOME AND INCREASING OUTRAGE ID
FREE TAX PREP FUNDING. THE
THIRTY MILLION DOLLARS THANK YOU
. NINE THIRTY FOUR YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON CHEN
MEMBERS MANY MITCHELL JOHNSON
FROM HUMBOLDT COUNTY I'M CALLING
IN SUPPORT OF THE SAUCE YOU TAX
CREDIT ITEMS UNDER ISSUE FIVE IN
THE COST OF CAL THE I. T. C.
COALITION THANK YOU. WE HAVE
LINE THIRTY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD
. MY NAME IS MONICA AND I'M
INVITED TAX PREPARER
VOLUNTEERING ALAMEDA COUNTY I'M
CALLING IN SUPPORT OF THE FOSTER
YOUTH TAX CREDIT ITEMS UNDER
ISSUE NUMBER FIVE AND THE
REQUESTS OF THE CALLIE ITC
COALITION CLUSTER YOU NEED THE
SUPPORT THAT THEY LEARN THE
SKILLS OF FINANCIAL LITERACY AND
TAX FILING THIS YOUNG ADULT.
THANK YOU. LINE THIRTY NINE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS THIS IS
JENNIFER CAVALERA FROM THE YOUTH
LAW CENTER CALLING IN SUPPORT OF
ITEM NUMBER FIVE THE FASTER YOU
TAX CREDIT AND THE PROPOSALS
FROM THE END CHILD POVERTY
COALITION IN COUNTY ATC WE THINK
THESE PROPOSALS WILL HELP YOUNG
PEOPLE AND FAMILIES FIND
ECONOMIC SECURITY AND ENCOURAGE
AND SUPPORT. THESE ITEMS ALSO
URGE THE LEGISLATURE TO INCREASE
THE CAL EIGHTEEN E. I. T. C.
MINIMUM FOR ALL TAX FILERS AND
FIND FREE TAX PREP ASSISTANCE
GRANTS WE ALSO THINK THESE ARE
CRITICAL AND SUPPORT AND WILL
HELP YOUNG PEOPLE AND FAMILIES
ACCESS REALLY IMPORTANT- TAX
ASSISTANCE THANK YOU. LINE FORTY
ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY NAME IS
MATTHEW AND I'M CALLING ON
BEHALF OF FIRST FIVE CALIFORNIA
AND I'D LIKE TO REMIND MYSELF OF
THE COMMENTS MADE BY MY
COLLEAGUES AT THE HELP I RECALL
ELECTION IN SUPPORT OF ISSUE
NUMBER FIVE THANK YOU. WE HAVE
LINE FORTY TWO. SHARE MEMBERS MY
NAME IS THE LORD. I. WASHINGTON
TAX CREDIT. FROM THE END OF HOW
PROPERTY. WHERE IS TRUMP'S FOR
OF THE GOVERNOR THE PUBLIC
BILLIONAIRE BRAKES ON A FACTS
BEFORE BOSS HE'S A JERK YEAH.
RIGHT EIGHT BUT.
THE MEMBERS AS WELL AS STAFF
FOR- TODAY'S BUDGET HEARING AND
WE ARE NOW CONCLUDED.